Well,
I took my first degree in political
science and I was interested in
motivation for social conflict primarily
and at the time I took my degree and I
suppose it's probably similar now,
all the explanations for social conflict
where economic,
no,
people are basically fighting over
resources of one form or another and
that that just struck me as wrong.
It's too simple.
And,
and it also doesn't explain why people
value certain resources.
It's not self evident that a resource
has value.
It depends very much on the cultural
context and it is also didn't seem to me
to take into account the relationship
between belief and the individual.
You know,
it was a purely economic explanation of
plus then it's also predicated on an
essentially economic view of man.
It wasn't deep enough to really explain
the issue.
And,
and at that time too,
it was in the early eighties when I
really started to think about this.
It was sort of the second peak of the
Cold War and,
and people were very,
very worried about nuclear destruction,
you know,
it was,
it was a constant background concern.
And so part of what I was curious about
was wha,
how belief could be important enough so
that people would be willing to put life
itself at risk to have produced this
insane standoff with these tens of
thousands of nuclear weapons and then
there was something beyond that too
because you can explain some of that
with just with territoriality,
but there was more.
There was an element of gratuitous
violence that characterize situations
like those in Nazi Germany and also in
this Dell,
in the camps and in lots of other places
as well.
But those were the two that really stood
out for me that I felt couldn't be
explained by law.
Certainly not by a resource theory or
even really by theory that had anything
to do with territoriality.
There was some other element that was
more metaphysical that wasn't being
attended to.
He just couldn't account for those sorts
of things.
You know,
it's one thing to kill people.
You could even make a rational account
for that in under many circumstances,
but to make them as miserable as
possible while you're killing them.
And then also to do it in a manner
that's counterproductive with regards to
your own ends,
because that clearly happened in Nazi
Germany.
That's not.
There's no straightforward rational
explanation for that.
So I started reading more and more about
that.
There was something about especially the
archetypes of the collective unconscious
and reading that in relationship to the
Gulag archipelago that I felt that there
was something there that really bore
further investigation,
you know,
and soldier knits and for example,
he concentrated a lot on the
relationship between individual deceit,
particularly lying to put it simply and
the pathologies of the state makes a
very clear case for that.
And I'd always sort of interpreted
Freud's idea of repression as a form of
lie.
Now I don't think his account of
repression is,
is correct,
but it doesn't matter.
It's interestingly wrong at least,
or it's approximately right.
Something like that.
And then there was a weird connection
between this idea of the lie as the root
of pathology in totalitarian states and
archetipal religious ideas of that were
associated with the idea of good and
evil.
And so that started to attract my
attention.
I was probably about 20,
it was 1982,
yeah,
I was 20 and I was also reading
Nietzsche at that time and I read
everything that he wrote that the of his
major works.
I mean the whole collected works,
which hadn't been published yet,
but I read them in chronological order
and that was extremely interesting for
me as well.
And there's,
there's a very interesting intellectual
relationship between Nietzsche and young
and Solzhenitsyn in the soldier nets and
connection is more through Dostoevsky,
Dostoevsky a new or a niche and we're
investigating very,
very similar ideas at exactly the same
time.
So there's these weird parallelisms of
thought and although people don't
understand,
know what well young was extremely
influenced by nature just as much as by
Freud.
I mean he,
he.
There are,
there is a publication,
for example,
that's notes on his seminar on thus
spake Sarah Oostra and it's like 2,600
pages long and it only covers the first
third of the,
of thus spake Zarathustra.
So the young was very interested in
nature.
So these,
I found this source of ideas,
which I suppose was grounded in some
sense in 19th century romanticism that
seemed to really get at the root of the
question as far as I was concerned.
So because there's something,
there's something that isn't just,
it's not just rational behavior that
drives people towards war.
There's an irrational element of it that
you can't explain without.
I don't think you can explain it at all
without recourse to religious language.
It's the only language that's deep
enough to get at it properly.
So
I started reading all this,
like I didn't understand the archetypes
of the collective unconscious at all.
So I read it again and then I read it
again and then I,
then I started to understand what,
what he was talking about a little bit.
You know,
the,
the idea that these,
that there were patterns of action and
perception in a sensor or cognitive
categories.
That's another way of looking at it
that,
that lie at the bottom of our thoughts.
They structure the way that we look at
the world and they have deep
evolutionary,
a deep evolutionary basis,
and
they have the quality in a sense of.
And that really,
that really frightened me,
that idea,
you know,
one thing he said,
which I really love,
he said,
uh,
people don't have ideas,
ideas have people.
I thought,
oh yeah,
that's a really interesting way of
looking.
It's like Richard Dawkins idea of meme.
It's funny to read,
darkens,
darkens is someone who is almost to the
point where he could read you because
this idea of memes and the archetypes
are very,
very close,
except the meme is a trivial concept
compared to the archetype.
So an archetype is like a metal meme in
a sense.
It's deep.
It's so ancient that it,
it's tangled up in our biology.
So darkens,
even though he's an evolutionary
thinker,
is still like a post enlightenment
rationalist.
You actually can't be a post
enlightenment rationalist at an
evolutionary thinker.
That doesn't work well.
You're too concerned with rationality.
Rationality is new.
Hardly even matters.
Some sense.
So anyways,
so I was obsessed with the,
with the idea of destruction.
And the will to destroy fundamentally
and its expression and totalitarianism
and then its relationship with the
history of ideas in general.
That's partly why found niches so useful
because Nietzsche predicted that the
20th century would be award in some
sense between while certainly a war that
was,
that would involve communist ideas.
He,
he predicted that about 18,
60,
something like that in will to power.
He said,
you know,
we'll pay for that conflict with a
couple of tens of millions of lives,
which is quite the prognostication like
30 years before the fact.
And then you also talked about nihilism
and both of those as a reaction to the
collapse of Christianity.
And that struck me as highly plausible.
So,
so nature was also extremely useful.
See,
one of the things about young is that
young spend his whole career trying to
answer niches question.
So Nietzsche said basically that the
conflict between enlightenment thinking
and religious thinking,
Christian thinking in particular was
going to wipe Christian thinking out,
or at least people's ability to believe
in the metaphysical assumptions that
underlied Christianity and that the only
proper response to that would be
nihilism.
Which he was very much concerned with or
authoritarianism,
and so Nisha was trying to develop a
philosophy of what might constitute a
third path and that's expressed to some
degree in thus spake Sarah booster with
the idea of the superman or the
overmanned.
But
that idea really never got developed.
In fact,
you believe that the development of that
idea was part of what drove Nietzsche
insane.
He,
he thought that he developed a kind of
schizophrenia.
Inflation,
believe that inflation was the invasion
of the conscious ego with archetipal
content.
And so it's almost like when the old
hero dies,
a new hero is born and that new hero in
some sense was born within niches
consciousness.
But those are experiences that are
powerful enough in some sense to have a
psychotic element to them.
And anyways,
Nisha died before he developed those
ideas very far,
but then young spent his entire career
in some sense trying to understand here
on mythology,
fundamentally
through a lot of people who insist that
religion or otherwise supernatural
belief systems are mythologies,
are relics from the past.
Um,
you know,
from another era.
And they're either naive faulty
descriptions of actual material reality
the same way that we think of science
today,
or they're.
They were kind of a,
a crowd control tools,
Straw man arguments.
Fundamentally.
I mean,
one of them is just Marxist,
you know,
it's like water power structures there
for while they're there to serve the
purposes of the elite.
It's like,
no,
that's one of their purposes.
That mono mania,
that,
that insane desire for singular causes.
To me,
that's also the expression of an
archetype.
It's monotheism inaction.
It's like,
you know,
so you see these people who,
who,
who claim to be atheistic,
they just invented new God.
Fuko did that with power for.
I did that with sex.
You know if you're smart too,
you can take a major motivational drive
or system.
They're not really drives.
They're really personalities.
You can take a major motivational
personality like power sex and you can
explain everything on its basis because
everything is.
Every human action is motivated by the
major motivational systems,
some ad mixture of them.
And then if you're smart enough,
you can always figure out a way that
some complex phenomena is related
causely to some simpler motivation.
But it's intellectual masturbation as
far as I'm concerned.
It's not the attempt to explain
something,
it's the attempt to reduce everything to
one simple principle that you can be
master of now.
So that.
So you know,
was religion for crowd control?
Well it's just a,
that's an empty theory.
Well what,
so this is what a multigenerational,
a conspiracy.
That's what it is.
It's,
it's a conspiracy that stretches as far
back into the past as we could imagine.
Right back to where people were tribal.
And maybe farther back than that.
I mean,
that's not an explanation.
And the,
the other one,
the a supernatural.
Well you know,
there are,
there are people who think they think
scientifically but they don't because
they're not very good at it.
And then there are people who think
scientifically at a genius level,
it's like,
well,
there are people who think they think
religiously but don't.
And then there are people who think
religiously at a genius level and you
can't assume that you can use the same
motivational explanation at every single
level of analysis.
So yes,
there are elements of religious belief
that are superstitious,
although,
you know,
that's,
that's kind of a slight of hand too
because if you want to argue that
religious religion is only superstition,
you collect up all the superstitions,
you define them as religious and then
you define religion as a collection of
superstitions.
So you know,
it's,
it's not very careful articulation of
the whole class of phenomena that are
attempting to be that,
that,
that people are attempting to explain.
And there's also a big difference
between explaining and explaining away.
So.
Well Dennis likes to explain away things
like consciousness,
you know,
and you can't explain away consciousness
while you can.
It depends on how you structure your
initial presumptions about the world,
you know,
so the logos that we were talking about
earlier that's associated with let's
say,
articulated truth and the communication
of articulated truth,
that's basically the prime function of
consciousness.
And the,
the Judeo Christian story is predicated
on the idea that that is a fundamental
element of being.
Now you can,
you can structure your world with
different presuppositions.
So you could say,
well,
consciousness is an EPA phenomena of the
material world.
Well,
you can make a perfectly coherent and
useful set of tools out of those
presuppositions,
but that set of tools does not cover
everything that you need and it's no
more viable as an explanation than the
explanation that no consciousness is
somehow fundamental to being.
And of course being is different than
material reality.
So,
and these things aren't grappled with
properly by positivistic scientists who
have no real training in philosophy and
who knew nothing at all about religion.
You know,
their religion,
the Christianity that Darkens,
criticizes is the Christianity that a
smart 13 year old boy objects too.
So it's like,
well,
how can you reconcile genesis with
evolutionary history?
It's like,
well no,
that's really not the problem.
So it's a straw man argument.
Hello,
ugly.
You better sit.
Sit,
lay down,
lay down.
One of the things that I've learned
about argumentation is that if you're
trying to distinguish between the
validity of two
different worldviews,
you want to make the strongest possible
case for both worldviews.
You're not trying to be right.
You're trying to figure something out
and the easiest way to be right is to
make your opponent into an idiot,
so there is no doubt that empirical
science has kicked the slats out of the
way.
People think about religion because it
wasn't easy for people to understand
that there could be different,
that different systems of thought might
have different purposes.
You have to be a philosopher of thought
to think about that even,
and I don't think it was.
I don't think that became obvious at all
until after Nisha
not all
belief system served the same masters so
to speak,
and so
you can't assume that every system of
thought is doing the same thing
and then
you can't assume also that there's only
one way to formulate your basic
assumptions about the nature of reality.
I mean,
heidegger,
I didn't discover the relationship
between the system of thought that I
derived say for a mutual and young and
some other people that are,
I read and heidegger until much after I
had written maps of meaning,
but heidegger's study of being is
predicated on the idea that being is the
fundamental reality and that is not
objective reality.
It's not material reality.
It's lived experience.
Something like that.
Lived experience is real.
Okay,
that's a presupposition.
So you start with that presupposition.
Then you ask yourself,
well,
what are the basic elements of lived
reality?
And then what happens there?
Or at least what seems to have happened
is that high heidegger identified the
same basic elements of lived reality
that I identified in maps of meaning and
one was
the social world.
The world is constructed by humans,
which I think is basically the,
an elaborate a dominance hierarchy and
it's permanent.
So this is where the issue about what
constitutes reality becomes very
critical.
Dominance hierarchies are 300 million
years old.
They're older than trees.
So if you think that's what one
definition of what's real is what's
persistent across time,
then it's almost impossible to find
anything more real about life than a
dominance hierarchy.
So to your point about lobsters,
I think absolutely,
absolutely.
It's the same bloody circuitry,
serotonergic circuitry.
I mean there's another circuit that
lobsters used that we don't have that's
based on Oct octa mean I think that's
the right word,
but a lot of the way that maneuver
within dominance hierarchies is the way
we maneuver within dominance
hierarchies.
If you're an evolutionary thinker,
you can't just push that away and
dominance hierarchies are,
although you can think about them as a
social construct there also for a
natural phenomena.
Right?
So the dominance hierarchy is actually a
major part of the environment to which
we have adapted.
Okay.
So there's the dominance hierarchy,
that's the,
we'll say the social world for the sake
of argument.
There's the natural world and there's
the experiencing subject.
While those are high degrees categories
of being as well and in in some sense
what what religious thinking seems to do
is to continually pause it.
Those three things as interacting
causally at the base of being so,
and that's not a material reality.
There's a lot of things about being that
we can't attribute simply to material
reality.
We may eventually be able to do that,
but by that time our notion of what
constitutes material will be much
different.
Okay,
so we.
We can't deal with subjectivity within
the confines of our materialists
theories,
not.
It's partly because those theories are
predicated on the elimination of
subjectivity as an aide priority move,
right?
The whole point of objective science is
to remove subjectivity.
Okay,
so then it gets removed and while you're
surprised about it,
it's like,
well,
no,
you can't be surprised about it.
You remove it right at the beginning.
Now that works for certain purposes.
It works very well,
but it has consequences and some of
those consequences,
as far as I'm concerned,
are serious enough to produce two forms
of social and mental illness and one of
those would be the succumbing to the
temptations of authoritarianism and the
other would be succumbing to the
temptations of nihilism because they're.
They're logical consequences of the of
the definition of subjective is no
unreal.
So now then you ask yourself,
well,
how do you determine whether or not a
theory is true?
Then you ask yourself,
well,
what do you mean by true?
Well,
then you're in trouble.
Okay,
because I think you can take a Newtonian
perspective on that or a Darwinian
perspective,
but you can't do both at the same time.
Yeah,
so nature said truth serves life.
Okay?
In some sense that's a Darwinian idea.
Okay.
If it's true enough so that if you acted
out or hold it,
that increases your chances of survival
and reproduction over long spans of
time.
That's true.
Okay.
We have no idea if our detailed
knowledge about the material world is
going to be the type of knowledge that
allows us to survive and reproduce over
a long period of time.
It's not been tested from a Darwinian
perspective at all and you might say,
well,
of course the materialist perspective is
right.
Look what we've built with it.
We've built hydrogen bombs,
for example,
but then you might object to that by
saying,
well,
yeah,
we've built hydrogen bombs,
but the only reason we could build the
more we're willing to was because we
left things out of the equation,
but what things.
Well,
things like,
is it really a good idea to build
hydrogen bombs?
For example.
I can give you another example of that.
Um,
I read a book a while back that was
written by a kgb officer who claim to be
exposing the inner workings of the
Soviet scientific community with regards
to a biologic warfare.
And the people in the institute that he
described,
we're trying to cross ebola was smallpox
because smallpox is extremely infectious
and Ebola is extremely deadly.
So like that's a valid scientific
enterprise.
Okay.
Then you think,
oh,
isn't that interesting that that's a
valid scientific enterprise because
obviously that's insane.
So then you think,
well,
if it's so obvious that that's insane
and it's a valid scientific enterprise,
well
there's some disconnect there between
two different views of what constitute
at least appropriate behavior.
Now you know that this is why the
definitions of truth start to become so
important.
It's like is truth as expressed to
action,
is it truth as it serves Darwinian
purposes?
Is it truth as defined by the axioms of
material of a materialist philosophy,
which by the way aren't even true
anymore because if you go down far
enough into material reality,
now we know you hit a realm that's so
bizarre that we can't even comprehend it
and it which has ended.
There's implications of that bizarreness
that we can't comprehend.
So I would say we will develop a
materialist philosophy of consciousness
eventually,
but it won't be using the same material
that we use now.
Right?
So,
so if I understand correctly,
you're talking about there's the,
let's say the industrialized north in a.
In a society that relies on scientific
analysis to to make it make it,
to establish the fundamental bases on
which does the rest of the society is
predicated.
Yeah.
There are certain assumptions about what
is real versus what is not real.
What is what is actually out there.
If there's a distinction between
subjects,
but even there,
there's an implicit assumption that's
what's out there in objective space is
what's real.
Okay,
well,
but the problem with that is that that's
an assumption about reality.
Now it's obviously a powerful
assumption,
but here's another way of looking at the
Darwinian problem as far as I can tell.
So part of the reason that the
Darwinians insist that random mutation
is the source of
continual,
it's not progress.
Continual survival is that the
underlying environment changes and it
changes unpredictably by,
by,
by its essential nature,
it's unpredictable.
Thus,
if it's unpredictable,
only random transformation can keep up
with it.
A lot of random transformation.
Hopefully the randomness of the
environmental change will be matched by
the randomness of the genetic change.
Okay?
So what that means in part is that the
environment,
so to speak,
is finally incomprehensible because you
can't predict it.
Okay?
So that means that a limited creature
that's established itself by Darwinian
means can't have access to the truth.
They can only have access to sufficient
truth and sufficient truth is the truth
that allows you to survive and
reproduce,
and from a Darwinian perspective,
there isn't any truth past that.
So I don't think Dawkins is a Darwinian.
I think he's a Newtonian because he
believes that there is truth.
The Darwinians don't believe that the
Darwinians say no,
there's enough truth to keep you alive
and have you survive,
and that's all.
And eventually all that's going to go
to.
Because you know,
99 point five percent of all species are
extinct.
That's an amazing point.
If I understand it correctly,
the American pragmatists figured this
out at the late 18 hundreds.
Exactly.
That this reminds me of pregnant.
His philosophy specifically,
which I have a soft spot for.
It speaks to me directly,
but I'm thinking about other people who
will do I know what the university or
just in my life if they hear this,
they would just say what like.
So it's as if we're living in two
different worlds.
At the same time,
we are in the sense that we.
We've internalized the,
the evolutionary mindset for a large
part and parcel of,
of how we understand reality,
but at the same time we pulled onto this
notion of truth as beyond our subjective
experience out there,
and we're actually directly when we
conduct these experiments.
This is just true,
right?
Well,
it's all part of the problem too,
is that because,
because,
um,
sciences,
reductionistic,
whenever you measure something extremely
accurately,
there's a whole bunch of other things
that you're not measuring.
And your assumption is that the
knowledge gained by that precision isn't
undone by the dismissal of everything
else.
Well,
is that a valid claim?
It depends on what your preconditions
are for determining validity.
Like automobiles,
automobiles,
get you from point a to point b,
you might say,
well,
that's their fundamental purpose.
That's what they were designed to do.
But I could say,
well,
no,
it turns out that their fundamental
consequence,
if not purpose,
is the complete transformation of
cities,
the demolition of the rural communities
and the destruction of that noosphere.
It's like,
oh,
we left something out.
Yeah,
you left something out.
So you gain,
you gain precision,
but you pay for it with a loss of
something else.
And then there's the other problem,
which is the pragmatic problem,
which is truth for what
you know,
it's difficult for me to say see that
it's dangerous as far as I'm concerned
to considered truth independent of its
effect on us.
So I think if a truth drives you insane,
it's not a truth.
There's something wrong with it and
that's like a definition,
but,
but I think it's a definition that's
grounded in Darwinian thinking.
And I think what I think about religion
is a very dark Darwinian.
I think religion is an evolved.
It's evolved knowledge and it's
knowledge about action and the world is
made out of action.
So especially the human world.
So you can't say,
well that's not real.
It's like that's wrong.
It's real.
It's not something you can easily reduce
to causal relationships between the
fundamental building blocks of matter.
But not only is it real,
everyone acts like it's real.
And then I would say,
well,
I don't care what people say about what
they think about,
what's real.
I care about how they act because that
actually shows what they really believe,
so and whatever their rational mind is
computing and,
and you know,
chattering about on the surface,
it's like,
who cares about that?
They're just possessed by ideas.
You know,
they may,
they might be defenders of the ideas
too,
but that doesn't mean they believe them,
you know,
depending on how you define belief.
Right.
Okay.
So this is,
this is getting to the crux of it.
I think it will be good luck with the
rest of the discussion.
So we're talking here about truth,
not a reinterpretation of truth from an
objectivist positivist scientific
perspective,
which we've inherited from the
rationalist area.
You're saying,
what's a return to the original
conceptions of truth,
right?
Along with the American pragmatists and
in light of a Darwinian insight into
what life is the about the pragmatists.
Like I said,
as soon as Darwin published the origin
of species,
they recognize that the theory of
evolution was pragmatic.
They got it.
Like right now,
they were very excited about it.
So.
And they got excited about it because
the Darwinian claim is things are always
true enough and that's it.
And it isn't in some sense even because
you lack knowledge,
it's because you couldn't have the
knowledge,
even hypothetically without running a
simulation as complicated as the world
itself.
And even then it wouldn't turn out the
same way.
Deleon view of reality in the sense
that,
you know,
any,
any explanation of the complexity of the
system is,
is doomed to be simpler than the system.
Yeah.
Yes.
That's one way of thinking about it.
Sure,
sure.
Well,
you,
you could think about it as.
That's right.
You can think about it as a limitation
of the perceiver.
The problem too is that whatever
knowledge you crew about the system
changes the system.
It's like trying to predict the stock
market,
which isn't possible.
Right?
So I think that's a really good example
actually.
And you know,
tried to predict the stock market
rationally.
See how you do what you might say,
well it's not real.
It's like,
okay,
well we don't agree about what
constitutes real so we can have that
discussion.
It sounds like what you're saying is
that truth is as much about action as it
is about some sort of material,
measurable objectives.
No,
I'm saying it's more about action more.
Oh yes,
yes.
The fundamentals of truth are,
are those that guide action and then the
objective science is nested inside that
it has to be.
There's no way around that.
Okay.
So that,
that,
that I think is a really central because
everything in my mind,
everything in maps of meaning and a lot
of your other work flows from there.
It's a different way.
Yeah.
Priority.
That's right.
Maybe we can elaborate that a bit.
Okay.
Well,
let.
We could do that.
Darwinian.
Let's do it from a Darwinian
perspective.
Okay.
So first of all,
there's the single celled animals will
say,
well,
we don't have to talk about them.
What,
what we're going to start to talk about
is animals that have a complex,
a sufficiently complex nervous system to
have to respond to the social
environment which would be made out of
conspecifics often.
So lobsters are a perfectly good place
to start.
It's like once lobster,
lobster,
and then there's another lobster and
maybe they're alone.
Well then they only have to solve the
problem of being one lobster,
but then as soon as you put them
together,
they have to solve the problem of being
too lobsters in the same space,
and then maybe there's 100 lobsters in
the same space,
so then the question becomes how do you
organize lobster behavior when most of
the environment consists of other
lobsters behaving and the answer to that
as being you put it,
you make a dominance hierarchy,
and then the dominance hierarchy,
the way you adapt to the dominance
hierarchy is by noting the patterns of
behavior that compose it and by first
internalizing those,
let's say modeling them to the degree
that that's possible,
but even more remarkably over huge
expanses of time because of the
dominance hierarchy and it's patterns
are a fundamental element of reality.
You start to adapt biologically to the
dominance hierarchy,
so okay,
so now what we've got is we've got an
emergent set of of social behaviors,
okay?
They're not rules because they're not
real until you observe them or until you
codify them or til you would articulate
them.
What they are is the patterns from which
rules emerge and they're deep patterns,
so then you might say,
okay,
what are the rules for staying alive in
a dominance hierarchy,
not being torn apart by your
conspecifics and that's learning quickly
who can tear you into pieces and who
can't,
and learning how to get away from the
thing that can tear you into pieces
quickly and learning how to push the
thing that can't aside and you'd better
learn that fast and you want to learn it
with the minimum possible amount of
damage because that's another problem
that social creatures have,
or at least creatures that are in a
dominant Turkey.
It gets even more complicated when the
members of the dominance hierarchy start
to cooperate.
But lobsters,
as far as we know,
as far as I know,
don't cooperate so but still like their
behavior is very,
very determined by the nature of the
dominance hierarchy.
Okay,
so what that is,
the patterns that govern a dominance
hierarchy are the place from which
ethics derive right,
and they evolved there and they're not
arbitrary.
That's the other thing.
What works in one dominance hierarchy
works in another.
And so you might say,
well what's your proof for that?
And why would say,
well,
one of my approvers for that is that we
use the same brain chemical and the same
neurological system roughly speaking,
to keep track of our position in the
dominance hierarchy as lobsters do and
that's 300 million years of continuity.
So.
So that's real enough as far as I'm
concerned.
So okay,
so now you've got your lobsters and find
that they organize themselves according
to these rules and the top lobster is
confident and makes himself big and he's
the one that gets all the chicks.
So.
So your success in the dominance
hierarchy,
especially if you're male also
determines the probability of your
reproduction and it may determine that
more than anything else.
So how to maneuver in the dominance
hierarchy,
be the prime question that faces
creatures that have to live with
conspecifics and the females in some
sense use the dominance hierarchy as a
distributed computational device to
determine the worth of the males.
So because what the females do is they
sort of hang off to the side and they
watched the males battle it out and then
they just pick from the top.
Now they have their own hierarchy and
you know,
it runs by somewhat different rules,
but it's very smart.
He'd say it's,
they're externalizing the cognitive
problem to the structure itself.
So okay,
so,
so then there's the rules that govern
the dominant Turkey,
the simple one,
which is just where they're the same
animals,
but they're competing.
But then when you get a little farther
along,
you know,
maybe to the point where animals are
hunting together,
that might be it or,
or caretaking,
something like that.
Anyways,
we're cooperative.
Behavior emerges.
Okay.
Now,
different rules start to apply because
like in a wolf pack,
let's say the wall still wants to get to
the top,
but he doesn't want to tear everyone two
pieces as he climbs to the top because
if he did that,
then he won't be in a pack and then that
that's not going to work.
He's going to starve to death.
So that really gets complicated.
It's like you can defeat someone but you
can't destroy them.
Okay,
there's another more rule.
You can defeat someone but you can't
destroy them.
So you might say,
well,
that's a rule that emerges spontaneously
as a consequence of social interactions
under biological control.
And once the rule emerges,
the dominance hierarchy lasts long
enough.
So evolutionary pressure can start to
operate to ensure that creatures within
that system build their ability to
follow that rule into their nervous
systems because it's the main selection
force,
whether they're successful at it.
So what seems to be arbitrary and social
can become built in and biological,
I think faster than we understand,
because the consequences of being
victorious in the dominance hierarchy
are so high.
So in the wolf hierarchy,
it's sort of like
we got hunt together,
we're going to have disputes about who's
boss will settle the dispute
symbolically,
fundamentally,
right.
All threaten you.
You threatened me.
One of us will blink,
the guide that blinks,
rolls over,
throw shows his throat.
You pretend to rip it out,
but you don't.
And we accept that as a proxy for
battle.
And so you're making the case that will
operate symbolically.
No,
not at all.
It's just that it's coded in their
behavior.
Yeah.
You have to make a real distinction
between patterns of action and rules.
They're not the same thing because we
like to think that,
well,
if you see regularities in an animal's
behavior,
it's rules.
No,
it's as if it's following rules and from
more anthropomorphizing assumption,
but it's also a different.
It's also a different.
It's a level of abstraction above.
First,
it's the pattern of behavior.
Then if you observe the pattern of
behavior and you have the capacity to
make symbolic representations,
then you can make the symbolic
representation and those would emerge
first in image,
not in words,
image,
image in stories.
Right?
So that's like the dramatic sub behavior
and then it's behavior imitating
behavior.
That's drama,
that's like a Piagetian idea,
you know,
that you can use your body as a
representational structure.
That's what human beings can do.
That's what imitation is.
It's a big deal.
So,
okay,
so you've got the wolves and it's sort
of like,
this is great so far,
but it sounds like the argument is
building from lobsters to um,
and this is how I'm interpreting from
lobsters to a strong argument for
essentially why Union archetypes
actually.
Absolutely,
yes.
Well this is very important.
This is.
But I think what's also important is to
help you help viewers understand how we
get from lobsters and dominance
hierarchies to no problem.
Truth.
Okay.
So they're not things they're
constituent elements of ray of reality.
That's not the same thing.
Okay.
And,
and a constituent element of reality is
in some sense depends on the thing,
but it's,
it's longevity is sufficient to make it
more than merely a thing.
Things are kind of temporary.
I mean,
protons aren't,
but you know,
things are temporary dominance
hierarchies,
those are not temporary.
Those are eternal.
They're eternal as far as we're
concerned,
you know?
Okay,
so you got the wolf and then you think,
well,
what kind of wolf gets to the top and
you might think the toughest wolf that
sort of like the caveman theory,
you know,
but it's unlikely that it's the toughest
wolf.
It's a wolf that's well adapted across
multiple dimensions,
but this,
the wolf that successful in the
dominance hierarchy you could think of
as the archetipal wolf right now.
What kind of Wolf is that?
Well,
I don't know enough about wolves to
know,
but I do know some things about dogs
mean a dog is cooperative as well as
competitive and it's,
it's pretty sophisticated at picking up
the cues that indicate the nature of
social relationships.
Like it can do that in human society.
The dog doesn't know the rules,
but the dog has the morality of a
dominant system already built into it.
So it's,
it's a predicate of its,
of its biological existence.
Okay.
So we'll switch to chimps because you
can actually talk a little bit more.
So with a little bit more concrete
knowledge about which chimps when says
lot from de wall,
which chimp stays on top because
mailchimp's make a pretty vicious
hierarchy,
right?
And it's almost always a male on top.
It's not so clear with Bonobos,
but Benobos,
I never know how to say that,
but.
But the chimp that stays on top,
brutal chimps can rule for a while,
but because they're brutal,
they're not very good at making
coalitions and even if your brutal and
strong to guys that are half as brutal
as you and three quarters is strong,
we'll take you down and that's what the
chimps do.
So then you might say,
well,
in order to be optimally situated for
maximum reach reproductive potential,
not only do you want to climb the
hierarchy,
you want to climb it without being hurt
too much.
You don't want to blow the straps out of
your group and you want to stay there as
long as possible.
Okay?
So that's a niche.
Think about that.
That's a niche.
It's complicated because the niche
involves success in climbing and then it
involves success in maintaining and
upper most position.
Okay,
so and that for chimps that requires not
only the capacity to be aggressive but
also the capacity to be cooperative and
empathic.
So one of the things to all discovered
for example,
is that the chimp who stays on top first
of all can make coalitions,
so there's a lot of reciprocal grooming
and so on,
so he's,
he can make friends even though he's
kind of,
you know,
he's tough,
but he also pays a lot of attention to
the females and the infants in the
troop.
So,
so whatever constitutes sovereignty,
let's say from a chimp perspective is a
lot more complex than mere power.
Okay,
so fine.
So that's chimps.
Now we're chimps,
so you already got the origin of human
ethics to some degree in that it's like
get to the top,
but don't be too much of a print when
you're there,
so to speak.
Right?
You have to,
you have to let you have to rule well,
making allowances for those,
for making and make allowances for the
fact that those you ruled over have
value.
Now that's an interesting thing because
now what you've done is if you've
introduced the,
not the idea,
but the fact that even a defeated other
is a valuable part of the group,
okay?
Now that that's starting to get
morality,
they're starting to get fairly deep
because that's kind of like,
well,
the outcasts still has value.
Okay,
now you come to human beings and you
think,
okay,
well what's what makes a human being
successful in the dominance hierarchy?
You can say,
well,
it's the same thing the chimps have and
that's right,
except that human beings have one other
thing.
At least they can make new dominance
hierarchies.
That's what creativity is,
right?
So you invent a new something and you
can erect a dominance hierarchy rounded.
So if you can't climb the dominance
hierarchy that's already here,
you can just say,
well,
here's a new thing and we'll make it a
little dominance hierarchy over there.
So now you've got the addition of the
capacity to transform the dominance
hierarchy as another thing that's
contributing to dominance hierarchy
success.
Okay,
so I believe that what's come out of
that is the idea that this is such a
great idea so that the top of the
dominant Turkey is the right place to
be,
but the top of all potential sets of
dominance hierarchies is a better place
to be,
and I think were selected to be the top
of the set of potential dominance
hierarchies,
and that means in some sense,
if you're at the top,
you're not at the top of ad dominant
Turkey.
You're at the top of,
okay,
so now imagine this.
So now imagine a landscape,
okay?
Far as you can see,
it's a plane and there's pyramids all
over it,
of different sizes,
right?
And you're flying above it and use zoom
into a pyramid and you see all people
packed inside trying to climb to the
top,
but there's pyramids everywhere where
people are doing this,
but you're flying along the top.
Okay,
well that's as far as I can tell.
That's the Egyptian God.
Horus.
Horus isn't in the pyramid.
He's above the pyramid.
So.
And he's the eye because horace is the
eye and so horace stands for attention.
And so there's this idea that the
Egyptian start to play with that one of
the most important,
God's Osiris,
and he's like God of the pyramid.
He stands for security and stability and
the past.
But he can be wiped out by various
means.
So he's not permanent enough in some
sense.
Or he lacks something.
Father Architect essentially.
Yes.
Osiris is the father,
the great father.
It's half of the archetype because he's
the.
He started the positive element of the
great father.
He's,
he's not the negative element,
although he makes himself susceptible to
the negative element by being willfully
blind.
Okay.
So his son is horace and horace is the
eye of Horus pays attention.
So the Egyptians are starting to get the
idea that,
well you should be,
oh cyrus.
That means you're the embodiment of the
dominance hierarchy.
Say,
but you also should be horus,
which is the thing that pays attention
because the dominance hierarchy as it's
currently structured may be
restructured.
And then so you don't want to just be
adapted to this dominance hierarchy.
You want to be adapted.
So if it transforms it structure,
that's no problem for you.
Because you're not stuck in it,
you're in it and not in it at the same
time.
And that's the big contribution of
Egyptian thought.
I think it's brilliant.
Brilliant.
Just a slight tangent,
what you're talking about there,
just to make that distinction clear for
other people.
When the Egyptians are experimenting
with these ideas,
are you saying that they're doing this
consciously or this is a,
um,
uh,
some,
some sort of natural happens
automatically level representation?
Yeah.
Well think about it this way.
So,
so imagine that one of the things that
characterize whether or not you can
climb the dominant Turkeys,
how good you are at watching people who
can climb the dominant Turkey and
imitating them.
Okay.
So that means that part of it's going to
be built in your biology because you've
been at,
you know,
the dominance hierarchy has been working
on you for a long time.
So you have the capability of being the
thing that can climb.
But then let's say you get an edge by
watching someone who's successfully
climbing because they're like adapted to
the current circumstances precisely and
you can imitate them.
Okay.
Then the question is,
well,
what does it mean to imitate them and
what it means is you can model their
behavior with your behavior.
Okay,
so that's a form of.
That's a form of representation.
Okay,
now you've got it.
Now we're all watching each other and we
find those people who can climb up
dominance.
Turkey is very interesting.
So we tell,
we start to tell stories about them,
which is the representation of behavior
in image and articulation.
So it's like you tell the story about
some interesting person that you admire
and then it's a pretty good story so
other people remember it,
but then it sort of gets commingled in
with some other stories about some
interesting people who can climb the
dominance hierarchy and then thousands
of you gathering those stories all have
a war over centuries and what you
extract out of it is like the most
interesting person who's the best at
climbing the dominance hierarchy and
that's where you start to get the idea
of the savior and so it's a bottom up
process and so.
And then once that's.
Once you started to get that,
well then the process can be more than
merely.
You can start to understand and model in
some sense what the principles are that
govern success,
but it's universal success,
right?
It's not success in a given hierarchy.
It's like what are the principles that
guarantee universal success?
So you might say,
well that's the ultimate question of
life.
It's like,
yes,
that is the ultimate question of life.
So what did the Egyptians figure out
while they figured out that,
oh,
cyrus was a good guy,
you need it,
but he's Kinda blind because he's old,
can be any.
He's willfully blind to and that makes
them susceptible to the forces that want
to overturn the hierarchy.
But the negative forces,
the ones that just want to destroy,
that's his brother Seth.
So Oh,
cyrus remains willfully blind and he let
seth basically chop them into pieces and
distributed throughout the Egyptian
state.
So things fall apart and seth rule.
So the Egyptians had already figured out
in models that the hierarchy can become
probably corrupted by power and deceit,
something like that.
Right?
So it's no longer functioning as it
should.
And it can continually do that instead
it descends into chaos or that's just
sort of.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it's the demolition of order and
well,
when Isis makes her appearance,
because she's goddess of chaos.
It's like outcomes.
Isis and her husband is so cyrus and
he's all chopped up.
So she goes around Egypt.
He's not killed because you can't kill
those cyrus because he's the dominance
hierarchy.
You can disrupt it,
you can break it into pieces,
but it's going to come back together.
So isis wanders around Egypt trying to
find his fellas.
So she finally does and she makes
herself pregnant with it.
And so the idea there is that when the
pieces of society fall into chaos,
they're still alive.
So something new can be born out of
them.
Right?
It's like the creative destruction that
the economists talk about.
Isis makes herself pregnant.
She gives birth to horace.
Now Horace is Cyrus his son.
But the big difference between him and,
oh Cyrus,
is that he can see he's not willfully
blind.
In fact,
he's the opposite of willfully blind.
He's almost only the eye,
the famous Egyptian I,
he's also a falcon.
And Falcons are those things that fly
above and they can really,
really,
really see.
So horace grows up outside the kingdom.
Well,
why?
Everybody grows up outside the kingdom
because the old kingdom has always
corrupt and are archaic and willfully
blind,
so you're always alienated from it.
So alienation is like a permanent
element of being.
But then horace goes and because he can
see,
he sees seth for who he is and then he
has a horrible fight with seth and he
wins and then he bandaged his seth.
Now you can't kill him because he said
it's like the fact that dominance
hierarchies can become corrupt is an
eternal facts.
So there is no getting rid of seth,
but you can get rid of them temporarily.
So when he gets rid of them,
he steals his eye back and then you
think,
okay,
well he's got rid of whole seth.
It's like he's got the kingdom end of
story,
but the,
that is what happens.
Horace takes his eye.
He goes back down to chaos and
underworld and finds those cyrus down
there who sort of like,
you know,
he's a ghost,
is a shade of his former self,
and horace gives him his eye,
so now cyrus can see with the eyes of
youth and then horace and Noah Cyrus go
back to really the kingdom together and
the Pharaoh is Osiris and horus
together.
If he's a good feral.
So that means he's wisdom and tradition
and attention and that's,
that's you're starting to get very close
there.
Now the Egyptians identified that
horace,
so cyrus thing with the immortal soul.
It's like,
yes,
they're right and it's not some trivial
superstition.
It's,
it's there,
right?
That is the immortal soul.
It's the thing,
it's the,
it's,
it's the best in each person.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Now you know that those ideas get much
more developed as we get much more
civilized.
So by the end of the Egyptian periods,
they call this the democratization of
Cyrus,
although only the Pharaoh to begin with
could sort of use the symbolism that was
associated with Cyrus Horace.
It sort of spread down the dominance
hierarchy.
So and then for me,
what happens after that is that while it
starts to get universalized,
right?
So this is not a particularly linear
progression,
but for the sake of simplicity,
we can make the case.
The Greeks give every adult male a soul,
right?
Well,
by the time Christianity rolls around,
it's like,
Oh huh.
Isn't it weird?
Everybody has a soul.
Even the Weirdos that you'd rather get
rid of.
Even those things that you think of as
enemies,
it's like it's in people.
Okay,
now Christianity really starts to play
around with exactly what the hell this
soul is.
And they,
you know,
the ideas come out in very bizarre ways
and like the,
the,
one of the most bizarre ways is that
Christianity makes the assumption that
the word of God,
that that pulls order out of chaos at
the beginning of time.
So logos is the thing.
That's Christ.
You know?
So many eons later they're the same
thing.
It's like,
well,
what the hell does that mean?
Well,
it's like if you embody the immortal
soul pro properly,
your,
the thing that generates order from
chaos or sometimes the reverse you make,
you know,
you're the transforming agent that sits
at the middle of order and chaos.
Okay,
so that's the same thing that was there
in the beginning.
Well,
that's the beginning of,
of being not the beginning of the
universe.
It's the beginning of being.
Those aren't the same thing.
So.
And the Christians figure out that this
logo's thing is very much associated
with articulated truth,
articulated truth.
And so the Christian idea in part is,
and this is,
this is where Dj had it wrong,
I think because he was,
he was,
he was too cynical about cyrus.
He was too cynical about Christianity.
He thought all it was was rotten
infrastructure,
you know,
so he,
he saw how it had become dogmatize and
corrupted across time,
but he didn't see what was in the center
of it and you know,
his superman was sort of a substitute
for that.
But he never fleshed that out.
Well,
but young started to play with the
superman idea and with the idea of the
philosopher stone and he was studying
Christianity and at one point he thought
he saw,
oh,
those are the same thing.
They're all the same thing.
It's complicated,
but one of the things that you
recognized was that the core doctrine of
Christianity in some sense is the truth
buttresses you most thoroughly against
the vicissitudes of being.
That's your salvation,
the truth,
the spoken truth.
It's not so you might say,
well,
people say,
Christians say,
well,
if you believe in Christ,
you're saved.
Well,
what do you mean by belief?
Exactly?
You say,
Jesus Christ is the son of God,
and you say,
I believe that just because you say
that,
it doesn't mean you believe it at all.
It has almost no bearing on what you
believe.
The question is how do you act and the
fundamental question that's under all
that is,
is your speech true?
Now?
Then you might ask,
well,
what is true mean?
Well,
unanswered.
That would be.
There's twofold.
What are you trying to do with your
speech?
There's two things you can do with it.
One is you can manipulate reality so
that it does what you want it to do,
so and that's the sort of speech that
people use when they're trying to get
what they want.
The problem with that is that there's no
way that they.
They can't actually know what they want.
They just hypothesize what it is that
they want based on some theory,
and then they try to manipulate the
world so that they get that,
but it's an unsatisfying venture and
often when they do get it,
it's not good anyways,
so and it involves a kind of falsity of
speech.
The other way is to try to say what you
mean and think and perceive as clearly
as you possibly can always and see what
happens.
Now the,
the story that underlies Christianity,
and it's not only Christianity but
Christianity that I'm most familiar
with,
is that the rule is live in accordance
with the truth and see what happens.
So in the sermon on the Mount,
for example,
Christ basically says,
set your sights on allegiance to God.
It's like whatever the highest value is,
we'll say and act in a manner that's
concurrent with that.
So that's your goal.
Then pay attention to the here and now
your best strategy for the future.
Well,
you know,
then you might say,
well,
prove that.
It's like,
well,
that's when the question starts to
become existential.
It's like,
well,
you can't prove it.
You have to try it.
That's like character guards,
leap of faith.
You cannot tell if this works unless you
do it.
And that's a commitment.
It's like it.
Those two ways of being like the
manipulative way of being.
That's an adversarial way of being
architecturally.
It's manipulative.
It's got the lie at its core.
That's completely different than this
path.
So.
So it's a hypothesis while inside
apotheosis that you and get a good job
of elaborating.
Although you know,
even with young,
it's not fully articulated.
He still saturated and image to a large
degree,
but no wonder it's very complicated to
make this,
this sort of thing fully articulated.
You read Solzhenitsyn's,
you think,
okay,
why did the Soviet Union become the
absolute hell hole that it was sold
units and says,
because everyone lied.
It's like,
oh,
isn't that interesting?
Well,
that isn't the hypothesis you hear every
day.
So then you think about Freud and you
think,
well,
what's the major cause of mental
illness?
Repression?
Well,
that's a lie.
Fundamentally.
I mean Freud's played around with it to
some degree,
so it's sort of like,
it's more like lying by omission
actually than lying by omission,
but it doesn't matter.
It's still lying young says the same
thing.
It's like,
oh,
well,
wouldn't it be interesting if the
fundamental root of psychopathology was
the lie?
The fundamental root of political
psychopathology is the lie.
It's like,
well,
what if that's what's demolishing your
life?
You know,
people say,
well,
people think,
especially when they're nihilistic and
they and they become destructive,
that the universe is sort of,
it's an unfair and arbitrary place and
it's basically bent on their random
destruction.
Well,
they suffer.
It's something like that.
Yeah.
Right.
Okay.
What do you do under those
circumstances?
That's the question.
Well,
one potential answer is twist the thing
so that you can maybe get what you
hypothetically want out of it.
The other is
rely on your perceptions and your
capacity for accurate representation.
Communicate that and take your chances.
It's like who's right?
Well,
that's the battle between good and evil,
who's right.
It's a continual battle.
I think it's really important to drive
home this notion of right and truth.
You're talking about here as in terms of
action,
what is the right action?
Because action is essentially is almost
the unit of truth that you're.
That you're hypothesizing based on but
for,
but for most people,
I think when they hear the word truth,
especially people in academia or people
are involved in the sciences in any way,
they think of something very different.
Yes,
of course.
And their truth is representational.
Right?
So can you elaborate?
Maybe.
See,
that's also.
That's also partly why the Catholic
church historically has been so put off
by the rational intellect.
You know,
like people like dark and say,
well,
you know,
yeah.
They went after Galileo because he was
undermining their superstitions.
It's like,
yeah.
Partly right,
the other part was seth,
like the figure of evil throughout
history is always the hyper rational
intellect and the reason for that is the
intellect is God's highest angel,
so that's Lucifer and it falls in love
with its own creations.
It likes to make totalities out of its
own creation.
Once there's a totality,
there's no room for the transcendent.
There is no god that Satan's error by
the way and everything immediately turns
into hail.
Now you see that was all put together
particularly well by Milton.
Milton was a visionary and what felt and
put together was the images stick sub
straight out of which the totalitarian
states we're going to grow.
He envisioned it.
Now it was visionary,
right?
He saw it as a battle between heavenly
agents,
but he codified it and he said,
well,
you know,
here's.
Here's the approaching problem.
Here's the problem.
That totalitarian intellect,
it's like,
and that's exactly right.
If you.
If you talk to people who are suffering
existentially,
they're always in love with the products
of their intellect.
They do not pay attention.
They say,
well,
I can't see how my life has any meaning
and answered.
That is you're not seeing your thinking
and you can easily think yourself into a
corner where your life has no meaning.
It's a cheap trick I can say,
who cares about this documentary?
No one.
It's not going to matter in a billion
years,
right?
Or in a hundred years or whatever.
I can pick a timeframe within which this
event is irrelevant.
Okay,
so then you can derive from that fact
that it's irrelevant or you can derive
from that fact that that's a stupid way
to think so and you can.
You can derive the conclusion that it's
a stupid way to think if you haven't
made thinking you're God so and there's
lots of other things that work better
than thinking.
Paying attention is better than
thinking.
It's much better than thinking.
Paying attention allows you to listen to
people who don't agree with you.
Paying attention allows you to learn
things that you don't already know,
so you know if it's thinking or
attention,
that should be the God.
It's like attention rules thinking
that's a subordinate phenomena,
but it likes to pop up on top,
you know,
because it likes.
It's a little tight theories and it
likes to be right.
Well,
you know,
forget that you're not going to be
right.
You could say that the image of Christ
is the West's attempt to most accurately
represent the,
the path of being that constitutes
success across an infinite set of
dominance hierarchies.
That's,
that's essentially.
Or that's,
that's at least one way of looking at
it.
Now there are figures,
hero figures,
you know,
because Christ is like a hero,
but he's sort of a Meta hero,
right?
He's the amalgam of many,
many,
many heroes.
But the hero is,
has key attributes.
Like the hero for example,
is always encountering chaos and
defeating it.
Well,
that's the human path.
You know,
we encountered chaos so often the snake,
well,
that also points to it's deep
evolutionary roots.
So there's a anthropologist,
Lynn,
Isabelle,
who wrote a book a while back called the
tree,
the serpent and vision.
I think I've got that right and she was
interested in why human beings can see
so well because we can see really well
the only things that can see better than
us are birds of prey.
And she thought,
well why
would a primate like us have such good
vision?
So she went around the world.
She thought she knew also that we were
particularly good at detecting the kind
of camouflage patterns that characterize
snakes,
especially in the lower half of our
visual field.
And she was kind of curious about that.
And then she thought,
well,
you know,
maybe we were preyed upon by snakes and
maybe we had to develop good vision
because we were preyed upon by snakes
like 60 million years ago,
way back when we weren't even people,
which is about how old snakes are.
It's like 60 million years,
something like that.
So then she went around the world and
she correlated the acuity of primate
vision with the prevalence of predatory
snakes.
It's like nice correlation.
So she thought,
oh,
human beings in snakes coevolved.
Well,
so what gives you vision snakes?
That's what it says in Genesis.
What else gives you vision?
Fruit.
That's also right.
That's why we have color vision,
right?
What makes you self conscious?
If you're a man,
women,
right?
That's eve.
So you know the stories in the Bible,
the pre flood stories,
they're really old.
We have no idea how old they are and
like they're extremely old and you might
say well and story for well like actual
story for them.
God only knows how old they are,
but in terms of behavioral pattern that
could easily be 60 million years old.
It's like the thing that defeats the
snake gets the women and you imagine
that in tree dwelling primates say well
upcoming the snakes.
It's like the first guy who figured out
how to drop a stick on a snake.
He was very popular so you know,
and so the snake,
what's happened is that religion.
So what what's happened as far as I can
tell is that the systems that our brain
evolved to detect basically rapacious
predators.
It's not just snakes,
but it'd be like reptiles with teeth,
predators in the dark,
things under the water,
like,
like crocodiles.
That's like,
that's the lurking a normally,
right?
It's the thing you have to contend with
and it's actually a monster.
You know,
people say monsters aren't real,
so like it depends on your timeframe.
If you add up and average all the
predatory monsters across 60 million
years,
you get a monster.
Okay.
The,
the,
so the,
the Amalgam of monster is a
representation of the class of predatory
stimuli.
That might be a way of looking at it.
Okay.
So we're very sensitive to that because
we were prey animals.
Okay.
Then our cortex leapt up a level of
abstraction,
so then that same system started to
detect anomaly as such.
It wasn't just the predatory thing that
was outside the dominance hierarchy.
It was the abstract thing that was
outside the system of ideas.
It's the same thing,
and so that became symbolized by the
chaos monster and we can easily throw
that our enemies.
It's like,
well,
who are you?
You're outside the hierarchy.
Oh,
you're a chaos monster.
While yes you are,
that's not a arbitrary prejudice.
It's like you are absolutely a chaos
monster.
Then the question is,
what do you do with chaos monsters?
One answer is killed them.
The other answer is get their gold.
That's a better answer because there's
information in chaos and we're
information scavengers,
and that's our niche.
It's like outside what we know.
There's information.
You might die retrieving it,
but if you don't die,
you're like a major hero.
Yep.
That's great.
So is this the sense in which these
religious or philosophical stories and
images are true?
Yeah,
in the sense that they instruct action
in a way that in the Darwinian sense is
true.
Great.
And that's the only sense in which truth
exists.
Well,
if you're a Darwinian,
right,
right.
So that's the problem with modern
scientists.
It's like,
are you Newtonian or are you Darwinian?
It's like Newton.
He's wrong by the way.
Right?
We already know that because Newton's
only a subset of Einstein,
let's say,
and God only knows what the whole
quantum thing is going to end up being.
We don't even know how to structure our
thought in accordance with those
presuppositions,
but Darwin,
trump's newton.
That's my hypothesis.
So you know,
you might say those who have.
So then the question is what attitude
towards religion is truly scientific,
right?
I think my attitude towards religion is
precisely scientific.
So because it's predicated on Darwinian
really on Darwinian presuppositions,
Dawkins is a rationalist.
He's not a Darwinian.
He just thinks he's a Darwinian.
Okay.
Can we.
Can we explore this a little bit in
terms of,
in terms of describing how you're
working with these definitions and
terms.
When you say that your approach to
religion is a Darwinian one and
doctrines is unwittingly perhaps
he's an enlightenment guy,
right?
So enlightened lightened is dislike.
It's really thin paint on a mile deep
piece of rock.
It's nothing.
One of the things I really liked about
reading young was that young tracks the
development of thought.
Say Back Ten thousand years.
It's like,
wow,
that's a 10,000
year span of history.
That's a long time.
It's like,
well,
not compared to 300 million years.
That's a really long time.
Okay.
So if we're going to talk about the
Darwinian underpinnings of the brain or
of the human organism,
let's use some time spans.
So darkens has darwinism painted on
enlightenment,
rationality.
He's a postseason enlightenment guides,
like rationality,
rules.
It's like this is how you make sense of
the world.
So like,
okay,
well we thought that more or less for
400 years.
So what did we think for the other like
300 million years?
How did we manage without that?
If it's truth?
So it's a form of truth.
It's a partial form of truth and it's a
powerful partial form of truth.
But to say it's truth.
Well then it depends on what you mean by
truth.
So yeah.
Well,
and that's where it gets back and
that's,
that's where it starts to go back into
the Darwinian issue,
which is there's only one way you can
define truth in relationship to finite
beings.
It's true enough,
true enough for what?
True enough so that you survive and
reproduce.
That's it.
You don't get to go any farther.
What's,
what's more true than that?
Sorry,
can't ask that question.
That's it.
You've hit the limit and that's
basically Darwin's claim and that's what
the pragmatist recognized as well.
So it was another way of really helpful.
What you just went through can be very
useful,
so is another way of articulating that.
What's true is what enables you to
successfully achieve a goal and you
know,
yeah,
no,
that's what.
That's what's true enough,
but there's only true enough,
but there's like there's varieties of
true enough so it doesn't turn you into
a relativist.
It's like some things are only true for
one thing.
Some things are true for 10 things,
some things are true for a million
things.
It's like,
well that's a better truth.
Well,
in what what,
what the religious imagination,
which is the imagination that's
concerned with values is always trying
to determine is well,
what's the highest value?
That's the religious question.
What's the highest value?
Which is what should you serve,
let's say,
to ensure your viability across the
broadest domain of time.
While we don't know,
so what we've done is,
well,
we've watched successful people.
What does successful mean?
Well,
we know what it means,
where we can stay within the Darwinian
framework.
I mean,
I don't think,
by the way,
I don't think the Darwinian framework is
the last word on things because we're
starting to discover,
for example,
that there are epigenetic
transformation,
so you know,
we'll see where that goes.
It's going to go somewhere very
interesting,
but that's okay.
For,
for the time being
were were,
were enamored of successful people.
Okay,
there's success.
There's a successful person,
a successful person,
be there,
successful person c and what makes them
the same is that they're successful.
Okay.
Then the question is what is successful?
Well then in some sense the variations
of Harold Mythology are complex answers
to that question.
It's like,
well,
if you're a hero,
you're successful while there's a bunch
of different kinds of heroes.
Okay,
so you get all of these heroes together.
Now have a big fight.
Who comes up on top?
Well,
I can tell you one answer to that
because that's exactly what happens in
Mesopotamian mythology.
It's there's a bunch of heroes,
their gods,
and then they're confronted by a
horrible chaos monster that actually
gave birth to them.
That's time at and they,
these gods,
they know that singly,
she'll just plow them to nothing,
so they're all freaking out about this
and then at one point a new God gets
born,
his name is Martin and he's kind of an
interest in God because he could speak
magic words and his eyes all the way
around his head so they send out a god
now and then to go after time out
because she's angry with them for like
making too much racket essentially and
killing her husband.
It's not a very good idea.
They're careless.
They're like two year olds really?
So they throw out a god now and then to
go fight time out,
but she just wants them.
There's not even any contest.
So they're,
this martyr is born in Negros up and
they're pretty impressed with him.
So they asked him one day,
well,
how would you like to go out and fight
time at?
And you know,
maybe he's not too thrilled about that,
but he says,
okay,
I'll do it.
But here's the rule.
Call a council.
You put me in charge,
I'm top God.
And that means from here on in,
I determined destiny,
so he's the thing that determines the
way the future's going to unfold and you
know,
they're not that happy about that,
but they arranged them into a hierarchy
and they put them on top and then he
goes out and he catches tie matt into
net.
So we conceptualize as her,
so to speak,
counselor into pieces makes the world
out of her.
It's like that's what a human being
does.
Pays attention to where the chaos is,
encapsulates it,
cuts it up,
makes the world.
One of his names was actually he who
makes ingenious things out of the combat
with ty.
Matt was actually like a literal name of
Martin.
And so the Mesopotamian emperor had to
imitate Martin.
So to the degree that he had
sovereignty,
the reason he had sovereignty was he,
he was a Martech and then he could be a
good martech or a bad mark.
So at the New Year's festival,
they'd take the king outside the city.
So that's out into chaos.
They'd strip him of his kingly clothes
and then they'd make them kneel and then
he had to confess to all the ways that
year he hadn't been a very good martech.
They'd actually hit him with something
first.
Then he had to confess while I wasn't a
good mark this way or that way and you
know,
so it got all his sins out in the open.
Then they had a big ceremony with the,
like the statues of the gods.
They replayed the battle between Marta
can tie a math and then they.
There was some other things that
happened to which I won't get into,
but then the.
Then they went back inside and the new
year was renewed,
so they acted out the the eternal battle
between attention say and embodied
detention and chaos,
and they realized that reverence for
that was the was the,
was the basis for valid authority,
valid authority,
and the king had a moral obligation to
act in that manner.
That's why he got two,
became like brilliant.
Now
you say,
well,
are they conscious of this?
They're conscious enough to act it out,
right?
That's as conscious as they were,
they could use their bodies and their
collective as a representational
mechanism,
but they couldn't,
you know,
and then they could tell stories about
it too,
but as far as deriving out what that
meant philosophically and in a fully
articulated way,
it's like,
no,
they couldn't do that,
which is fascinating for me.
So what that does,
at least in my interpretation of what
you're saying,
is that religious systems that are often
derided by,
let's say a mentor post enlightenment
thinkers for their,
um,
for axioms that are just not true or
false about the world,
right?
That's religious superstition.
It's clearly wrong.
It's backwards.
What you're saying is they were there,
they were and are very much true in the
sense that they are almost preconscious
representations of correct action
and the environment in which correct
action takes place,
which is fundamentally the dominance
hierarchy,
right?
We don't contend with protons and Adams,
we contend mostly with other people and
to some degree we contend with nature,
right?
But nature is sort of outside our proper
domain,
right?
That's partly why that idea infuses
environmentalism or it's like we've got
environmental ism is mythology,
right?
To the core.
It's like pure mother nature.
She's a virgin,
right?
And she's being raped by the terrible
father and the son,
his evil sons.
It's like,
yeah,
true.
But what about the good father and his
good sons and cancer and you know,
um,
well there was this horrible worm in
Africa that used to burrow inside
people's skin.
Yeah,
it's horrible.
And it was just eradicated day.
So some doctor took it upon himself to
get rid of that worm.
It's like,
yeah,
well that's mother nature to,
you know.
So Environmental Islam is an ideology
because it only tells half the story.
Of course people are patients and
horrible,
you know,
and Mother Nature is beautiful and
virginal.
It's like,
yeah,
but she's also an absolute terror and
you better be thankful for the fact that
you have a roof over your head and that
everybody isn't an adversarial rapist.
So you know,
you better balance out the story a
little bit.
So the,
the stories tell you how to act,
but they also tell you what the
environment is.
No,
not environment.
They tell you how to conceptualize.
They.
They modeled the nature of being.
That's the best way of thinking about an
actual b,
and in being is the social world.
How do you act in relationship to the
social world?
Let me tell you.
Oh yeah,
isn't that what you're saying?
Is isn't that different mythologies at
different points in time will tell you
how to act under particular conditions
in which that and wish that society
developed?
No,
no.
It's broader than that.
It's broad.
Well,
look,
I understood once who said,
well,
if these archetypes are true,
why don't we just tell the architectural
story over and over,
why do we need like literature?
And I thought,
wow,
that's a really good question.
And then I thought,
well,
for much of human history we just told
the archetypal story over and over.
Okay.
So,
but then there's this tension.
So this is why I think that there's
three persons in the Christian Trinity.
It's like there's,
there's the Holy Ghost will just forget
about him for a minute,
but there's God the father that needs no
explanation.
That's,
you know,
the benevolent element,
benevolent.
That's the great father.
And then there's the sun.
That's the hero.
Okay.
But the hero is weird because there's
this sort of logos hero that's been
there since the beginning of time.
That's logos,
right?
That's the word.
And then there's Jesus Christ,
the carpenter,
he's this guy that lived in,
you know,
some little bitty irrelevant village
2000 years ago and died young.
Why do you need him?
While it's because the universal isn't
real until it's been made.
Particular and what we are.
Our particular manifestations of the
universal and the particular and the
universal are both important.
So the general pattern is crucial,
but so are the details.
So,
so the archetype is a general pattern,
you know,
it's not,
you have your religious task in a sense
is to figure out how to embody the
archetype in actual time and space.
So it's a pattern,
but,
but you know,
you still have to fill in the details
and it's not like the details are
irrelevant.
They're really irrelevant details
culturally and temporarily specific in
some cases.
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
Let's say that's why we have Christ in
the Christian tradition,
but we have put in the Buddhist
tradition,
the Hindu tradition has its own plethora
with its own embodiments of universal
truth versus individual app.
My,
I mean,
because the va case you make for the
power of the,
let's say the Christian archetype
narrative is most familiar to us in the
West,
whether it's Georgia or otherwise
or while I also think that Christianity
has the best,
the most thoroughly developed philosophy
of evil.
So I think that's a big advantage.
So,
um,
but yeah,
I mean if you think about religions as
at least in part variations of hero
mythology,
which they are in part,
then it,
it's a story that can be told a thousand
times in a thousand ways.
I mean,
that's what a movie is.
If it's an adventure movie,
it's always a hero myth of some sort.
I mean,
Christ,
they're the ones we have now are almost
purely archetipal,
like all the superhero movies,
those are architectural right to the
core.
You know,
and it's funny because I know a comic
book artists or author,
he writes Batman and Wolverine and
there's a community that the
comic figure serves.
So if it's Batman and you're writing for
Batman,
you don't just get to do anything with
Batman.
There are Batman rules and the whole
community of Batman fans,
they know the rules.
And so if you muck about with Batman,
then they tell you.
So Batman is actually an archetype
that's been generated by the collective.
Right?
And they all feel,
well,
that's not quite right.
Well,
how,
why do you feel that the story isn't
quite right?
Well,
the answer to that,
it's like a platonic answers.
You know the story.
You just don't know that you know the
story.
And so when someone tells you the story
properly,
you think,
wow,
that's the story.
It's like lock in lock key and lock,
which is fascinating.
Is your argument bend?
We know it's right when we see it
because it's so ancient and.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah,
that.
And that's the other thing.
So there's.
Piaget had this idea of a equilibration
man,
it's a smart idea because piaget,
I don't know if you know this or not,
but the motivation,
Piaget's motivation was to bridge the
gap between science and religion and he
had very intense messianic experiences
when he was a young man.
Yeah.
So no one ever teaches that about
piaget.
Piaget is way more interesting than you
think.
The FDA was very interested in the
origin of morality and he traced the
origin morality back in some sense to
the rules that govern social
interactions.
Okay.
So you can think.
Piaget thought it really got going once
kids were able to play games with each
other that had a shared goal.
Okay.
So that was kind of Piaget's definition
of a gate.
It's like there's a bunch of people
cooperating and competing in
relationship to a mutually agreed upon
goal.
So like a monopoly game,
you know,
you want to get all the money.
It's like why?
Because everyone agrees that that's what
we're doing,
so it's like that's an artificial
dominance hierarchy.
We just whipped it up on the fly.
Here's the top value,
we'll play it out,
so then we're playing with his kind of
dominance hierarchy,
right?
You get all sorts of information about
people doing that and you also know,
clue yourself into the nature of
dominance hierarchies in the way that
they can be constructed even somewhat
arbitrarily.
Now,
what piaget noted was that children
could play together and they could get
along and they could pursue the goal,
but if you took them out when they were
young,
out of the context and you ask them what
the rules were,
well they didn't know because the rules
were actually the behavioral patterns
that all the kids had agreed upon.
One way or another.
They.
They didn't sit down and codify the
rules and then act them out.
They acted out a coherent action
pattern,
and then when polled from that,
they couldn't articulate it.
That wasn't the level at which the
knowledge was embodied.
Well,
that's.
That's exactly what happened to us
across the course of history.
It's like we learned to act before we
learned the rules for how we acted.
It's exactly the opposite of a
rationalist perspective,
by the way,
and nature was the first person to
really point this out.
You know,
he said that a philosophical of
philosophy is the unconscious confession
of a philosopher,
so in here you can think about this in
terms of of the story of Moses to.
It's like Moses realizes the rules,
right?
Because God gives them to him.
Well,
before Moses gets the rules,
he spends like years in the desert as
judge,
like all the Israelites who were always
scrapping with each other that get into
a fight.
They come to him and say,
okay,
who's right here?
And he's doing like all day for years
adjudicating.
So his mind is assembling all of these
instances of moral conflict and he
couldn't recognize patterns.
Well,
one day it's like it's a blinding flash
of illumination.
It's like,
oh,
these are the rules that we're
following.
It's the translation of the behavioral
knowledge into abstraction.
Now you know Moses is a composite
character,
although there are many stories about
the original law giver.
It's not the original law giver,
it's the original law observer.
Like we're our own wolf pack.
We're we're an anthropologist or or
ethnologist and wolf pack at the same
time,
oh,
here we are doing things.
What are we doing while we watch?
And we make stories out of it.
This is what we seem to be doing.
What are the stories mean?
This is what they seem to mean.
Oh,
those are.
Those are those rules.
They're articulated descriptions of
behavioral patterns.
We must be following them.
It's like,
well now we're following them because we
know what the rules are.
Before we were just acting out the
equivalent embodied pattern.
So,
and you know,
the like the conspiracy theorists,
you know,
the people who say,
well,
you know,
this is all about control by the upper
classes.
It's like they assume that you can just
generate up some arbitrary rules that
happen to serve you and then enforce
them on a community.
It's,
well,
no,
partly,
but fundamentally no.
You know,
because that,
that's not,
that's not biological thinking.
You know,
that's dawn of the industrial age
thinking or something like that.
Or post agricultural thinking.
Who cares about that,
you know?
Well,
let's go back to when we lived in trees
will go back 60 million years and start
talking about who we are from that
perspective and that's just the start.
We're older than that,
so it just.
It's too.
It's way too narrow a view.
It's not informed by biological reality.
When you mentioned the Moses story as
logged giver versus Law Observer,
and then I was thinking of the actual
biblical story of where God speaks to
Moses.
Then my introductions are my inner
enlightenment saying,
okay,
all well and good,
but why do you this ridiculous
sky figure who is a representation of
the dominance hierarchy?
That's the father.
It's like,
why not?
Okay that.
Let's talk about that.
What is it?
Agency detection module.
Okay.
First of all,
that's a stupid way to conceptualize it.
It is not an agency detection module.
It's not some little gadget that stuck
to a computer.
It's really deep.
Okay,
so let's think about who we are.
Monkeys.
Where do we live in a dominance?
Herc,
what's a permanent element of the
dominant Turkey?
The dominance hierarchy.
What else?
Well,
males,
females and you.
Okay,
so we're going to say what's the world
made out of males,
females,
and you.
Why is the world made out of that?
Because no matter where you go,
no matter when,
no matter how far back in time,
those are things you can rely on.
So then,
so now we have this circuit,
it's the brain.
It's like,
well,
what are males like?
What are females like and what are we
like and how do we interact?
Okay,
so there you get the constituent
elements of reality.
So first of all,
it's just social,
but it's complex because the males are
just singular figures like the father
isn't an individual.
The father is the whole patriarchal
dominance hierarchy,
right?
The individuals,
just a representation of that.
So our minds are more evolved to
consider masculinity as such rather than
the male individual,
you would say of Freud's problem
patients that they confuse their own
fathers with the masculine.
The masculine is like a God.
You say,
well,
is it a god?
It's like,
well,
it shapes your behavior.
It determines your destiny.
It determines your,
your fitness.
Is it alive?
That's a good question.
It depends on how you describe alive.
So okay,
so we've,
we've got this system that can recognize
like the masculine living thing,
the feminine living thing,
the self living thing.
Well that's the underlying priest sobbed
presuppositions of our nervous system.
That's the world of being.
Okay.
At some point our cortex inflates,
so now we can use abstraction,
but you know that evolution is a
conservative process.
You don't just build a new thing,
you call,
you build a new thing on an old thing
and so the new thing still thinks like
the old thing,
but it can do some more things.
Well,
so what's happened,
what's happened to us,
and this is something that's amazing to
me,
is that we've taken these basic social
cognitive categories and we've been able
to map being itself using the same
categories.
And it works.
You've mapped the masculine onto the
dominance hierarchy.
Umass Mac map the feminine onto nature.
Well that works.
All of a sudden that works.
It's like you can,
you can survive like that.
So you think,
well,
is that a metaphor?
It's like,
no,
it's not a metaphor.
Here's an example,
why is mother nature,
Mother Nature?
What's nature?
Well,
nature is that which selects.
That's as far as I can tell you Carl.
So you're going to define nature.
Nature.
Select women select.
I mean that's what women do.
Who?
Human women,
they're not like chimps.
They're selective maters,
so as far as men are concerned that
maybe as far as women are concerned to
women,
our nature,
it's not a metaphor.
It's like they're there.
The thing that stops you from
reproducing,
let's say,
and that's partly why they make you self
conscious.
When you rejected,
it's like they're the portal to
immortality.
That's another way of looking at it.
They are nature.
It's not like they represented.
They are nature in the most direct
possible way.
So like is that a right way of looking
at the world?
Too difficult to make an alternative
case?
If you think from a Darwinian
perspective,
now there's a metaphorical element to it
too because you can also projected on
that which lies outside of the
patriarchy,
which is also white.
Women get in trouble with men sometimes
because men can easily get confused,
right?
It's easy for women to be the chaotic
thing that doesn't fit in the hierarchy
and women are always complaining about
that.
Right,
and and as they should,
it's a constant battle,
but what's happened for,
for better or worse,
is that we've been able to take that
initial social cognitive architecture to
build a system of abstraction on top of
that to use the same basic categories to
explain how to behave and it worked.
So it's mind boggling.
It's mind boggling to me that,
that works.
So are you familiar with the theories of
embodied cognition and like,
and I'm like George Lake off in his,
his metaphor theory of thought.
Sure.
I think what you're saying is the same
thing,
right?
We have these categories that emerged
from our lived experience as humans in
our human.
Sure.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And because these are actually the only
tools we have,
we use them in recombination with each
other with themselves if nif necessarily
modification,
but we use them as ways of making sense
of the world.
Even our scientific models are
predicated on the,
the embodied experiences.
Yeah.
Well that's a tough one.
That's a tougher one because I do think
that there's.
The science does have a qualitative,
there's a qualitative difference.
It is in some sense stepping outside of
the mythological framework,
you know,
and it's because it's this really
powerful technique.
It's like,
okay,
what is the nature of our shared
experience?
Now it's,
it's.
That's not exactly what science is
about.
It's more like if we behave in such and
such a way something will happen.
We're going to that from a subjective
perspective,
like a personal perspective let's say,
but what happens if we get 100 people to
do that and they all observe the outcome
and then they all tell a story about it
and then we take what's common across
the stories.
It's like,
oh,
well that's interesting.
We get a new way of describing things.
Well,
is that true?
Well then you get back into the problem
of what constitutes truth.
Is it useful that we also don't know
that because we don't have the timeframe
across which to analyze it yet.
Like we're staking our survival on the
presupposition that it's useful,
but it's like there wouldn't be constant
bouts of apocalyptic thinking if we
didn't have our doubts about it.
Right.
And it's certainly an anomaly in the
natural world,
while no one,
no other creature has science.
It's like they did perfectly well
without it.
Maybe science is fatal.
I mean it could easily be fatal.
So you know,
and,
and someone who's a scientist in that
sort of ideological sense would say,
well,
even if it's fatal,
it was still true.
It's like,
well,
it depends on how you define truth.
Like if you're willing to say that fatal
is true,
well then go ahead.
But I think that's a not a good
definition of truth.
And that's where are our disagreement
really lies.
You have your definition now I have my
definition.
I think my definition is Darwinian.
So you have to contend with that if
you're a scientist,
but you might dispute that,
although it's not clear to me how you
would dispute that,
but.
Well we've already run through that
argument.
He'd gets tangled up at the bottom.
You know,
and I also think part of the problem
with strictly with the view that only
what is objective observable is real,
which you can have a science without
that presupposition.
You could say only what is,
what is objectively true is uniquely
useful and valuable,
but it's,
you know,
it's part of a bunch of things that are
uniquely useful.
Invaluable.
But let's not discounted.
It's also dangerous.
So we got to keep an eye on it.
You know,
it's a big tool.
Well,
that's perfectly reasonable thing to do.
What do you,
you take the next step and you say only
that.
Well then I also think another way.
It's like,
why are you claiming only that?
You say,
well,
it's because I'm pursuing truth and I
think,
Oh,
you're sure about that are you.
You actually think that like you're on
this,
you're sure that you're on this pristine
path and all those other people who
aren't there,
they're diluted or there's something
wrong with them,
but you,
you're on this pristine path.
You're so sure of that.
I don't think you know anything about
yourself.
If you think that it's like all
scientists are devoted to the truth,
what truth,
like
maybe they're devoted to the purpose of
demonstrating that there's no meaning in
life so that they don't have to bear any
moral responsibility.
It's like,
why not that,
oh,
we wouldn't think that.
It's like,
well,
I'm a psychoanalyst.
I might think that because whenever
anybody says to me,
I believe x,
I think,
what does it allow you not to believe
I'm for x.
What are you against?
Well,
I've thought about this a lot.
It's like,
oh,
it's a catastrophe that the,
the war between science and religion
blows the,
our capacity to believe in transcendent,
meaning it demolishes our ability to
believe in transcendent meaning.
Isn't that a catastrophe?
Sort of the Nietzschean viewpoint.
It's like I don't know if it's a
catastrophe because then I think,
alright,
well under what conditions would you be
motivated to accept that catastrophe?
Well,
you could say your life is meaningful,
but meaning comes at a price.
The price is basically moral and part of
that moral price is truth and
responsibility.
You have to bear that.
Okay.
It's like,
yeah,
you get meaning,
but now we've got some work to do.
You don't get to regard your actions as
trivial.
You don't get to rationalize your,
your errors of speech as as casual and
and a forgivable.
None of that.
You get the whole burden that goes with
meaning or you can say,
well,
nothing's meaningful.
Well,
Dostoevsky figured this out a long time
ago.
If there's no god,
there's no moral values.
Everything is permitted.
It's like,
okay,
maybe that's what you want.
Maybe your whole argument,
even though you don't know it.
Maybe that whole argument of which
you're only a part of is actually
predicated on the desire to demolish the
necessity for truth and responsibility.
So what you could say no.
It's like,
okay,
but you know,
it's not like science has always been
put to two purposes that we would regard
as ethical.
And then you also have to ask,
well,
what allows us to ask the question of
whether or not sciences put the ethical
purposes?
What's the framework for evaluation?
What's not scientific?
Well,
does it exist?
Soldier Nets and said something
interesting about the Nuremberg judgment
because he thought of that is like a
pinnacle event in the 20th century and
it,
I,
I can understand this because
like,
you know,
there was this Cartesian,
one of the things they cart did
hypothetically was to try to doubt
everything until he found something he
couldn't doubt and what he couldn't do
it was the fact that he,
he thinks now that's a,
that's a translation.
So I don't really know if he met.
I think whatever.
He had this process of radical doubt.
Well,
I did that too before I wrote maps of
meaning,
except I didn't know that descartes had
done it.
I was trying to think,
what do,
what do I actually believe?
What's,
what's unassailably true for me?
And I thought pain pain's
true.
It's really hard.
You can't argue yourself out of pain.
It's like when it happens,
it's real.
It.
No matter what you say about
subjectivity,
it's like you're running around
screaming,
so who cares what you say?
Now I thought,
well the infliction of pain is real,
and then I thought well,
if and pain is pain is unpleasant,
it's got that quality about it,
you know,
and I,
I,
so that was good.
And then there was another process of
argumentation that led me to conclude
that what constitutes a evil was the
infliction of unnecessary pain and for
me like so not only like if I'm really
evil,
I'm going to inflict pain in a way that
not only damages whoever I'm inflicting,
it also damages me and that's fine.
It's like the shootings and the high
schools.
It's like,
why don't they just shoot themselves to
begin with?
Why go to all the trouble?
Well,
try answering that.
You should read some of the writings of
the columbine killers,
man.
They'll make the hair on the back of
your neck.
Stand up.
You know,
it's,
you cannot believe what those kids
wrote.
It's,
it's uncanny what they were thinking
truly so.
Well,
they're motivated by something.
What,
what,
while it's something say panic from an
architectural perspective,
you know,
so for me,
what ended up at the bottom of reality
was it's wrong to inflict unnecessary
pain.
So pain even that's,
that's,
that doesn't serve your own purposes.
Even that's the Nuremberg judgment.
Fundamentally it's like there are things
that are wrong.
Okay,
are you going to accept that or not?
Well,
if you accept that there's a place you
go and if you don't accept that there is
another place you go.
And we already saw what happened when
people go to that place and so you can
say,
well that's irrelevant.
Okay fine.
You pay the price for your belief.
So will other people.
So for you know,
so that's why soldier and it's was at
least in part an admirer of the
Nuremberg judgment.
So like there are things that are
archetypally evil.
You don't get to his escape from them
because of culture.
You don't get to escape from them
because of the particulars of the
situation.
Well,
you could make a strong case that that's
victor talk and revenge.
Fair enough.
But when I wandered through the
Holocaust literature and the literature
on the Japanese invasion of China and
the literature on the stalinists camps,
that was sufficiently convincing for me,
it's like,
no,
not there.
That's not the right place to go.
Is that a scientific judgment?
No.
You're judging from your own logic.
Interesting that your judgment is
predicated on your existence as a human,
a dominance hierarchy,
and that's what makes that judgment of
the fact that this sort of behavior is
wrong.
True.
Because of the biological context almost
sure.
Which sure.
Which is embedded.
It's more than that because as an
individual I'm an individual,
but as a human,
I'm not an individual at all.
I'm this unbelievably old thing.
I'm like as old as life.
I'm really old while there's the me in
this,
which is this thing that was like,
come around in 1962,
but there's the deeper reality of this
thing that I am.
And that's the.
You could say,
well that's the union itself.
That's one way of looking at it,
but it has its nature.
It's the human nature,
not what good and evil are human terms.
You know,
now whether they refer to something
transcendent,
that's a whole different question.
It is not a simple question because we
don't know what rural consciousness
plays in being so I,
I like the deepest strata of thought
that I've encountered,
makes the case that the most real thing
is the eternal battle between good and
evil and I'm prone to believe that.
So what exactly that means.
That's a,
that's a different story.
It's complicated idea to,
to the.
My inner list in my brain now is saying
that that's a confusion of facts and
values,
but what,
what I'm what I'm assuming that you
would say back and correct me and tell
me what you would say back even as a,
as a materialist scientist,
you yourself are human participating in
this human drama.
You're better than one.
Yes,
that's right.
That's exactly right.
That's right.
Because that's the question.
Objective reality,
mythologies,
one,
proposition,
mythology,
objective reality,
another proposition.
That's my proposition.
It's like this is way deeper than this
to its incomparably deeper.
Now that doesn't mean this is deep.
It's deep,
but it's,
it's,
it's sterile and that's dangerous.
And then when you forget,
which is embedded in which then you make
mistakes,
it's like,
yeah,
well why not cross Ebola was smallpox.
Well,
that's a good question.
Why not do it?
Well,
you know,
a rationalist would say,
well,
I'm,
I'm capable of making that judgment.
Okay,
well let's really specify that.
What exactly do you mean that you're
capable of making that judgment?
Because again,
with Dawkins and his ilk,
you know,
they make the claim that they can have
their cake and eat it too,
is thinking of all the benefits of
eating evolved morality,
which is basically a Judeo Christian
morality in the West.
And they can say,
well yeah,
but we don't have to accept any of the
metaphysical presumptions.
It's like says who like,
yeah,
you could be right,
but why would you assume that you are.
So maybe the metal.
This is niches point.
Maybe the metaphysical presuppositions
are absolutely necessary.
So
the question that is asked by the
millennia old individuals or cultures
that gave birth to them or reinterpreted
as as preconscious symbology.
You see what I'm saying?
No,
no,
not exactly.
You have to specify that,
right?
Because then Dawkins might say,
or you know,
or I'll try not to pick on,
but then the materialist positivist
restrooms might say I'm okay,
but what does it mean to accept that
mythology or to accept the metaphysics?
Does it mean that I have to believe that
there's this omnipresent,
um,
you know,
uh,
a sadistic God who,
who pits nations against each other and,
and orders you to,
you know,
to,
to murder your,
that your neighboring tribe or rather is
it necessary to accept that metal,
those metaphysical to metaphysical
background with the substrate,
if you will,
in,
as understood now in,
as I'm Persian symbolic imagery from a
culture that had no other means of
articulating it so that [inaudible] then
they might say,
well,
sure,
I can,
you know,
I can accept that it had some value in
its time and place.
But so
no.
But okay.
That's where I would,
that's where the problem would start for
me still that time and place,
you know,
you get this idea too that like the
evolutionary psychologists do this.
Well.
Our evolutionary,
where we evolved was the African Savanna
and you know,
our moral systems are adapted.
It's like why,
why,
why?
They're like,
why not in the oceans 300 million years
ago,
you know,
like when,
why is that the preferential place from
which our values are derived?
The rest of it's just nothing.
It's like,
I don't understand.
That makes no sense to me at all.
Well,
you could say that's where we
differentiated from chimps.
It's like,
well,
so what?
We're not that different from chimps.
So you know,
what about the chimps?
They have a lot to share,
a lot in common with us.
They didn't go through the SAVANNA.
It's like,
so the idea that these values say are
shallow.
I mean if you put it in an evolutionary
basis and you go back to the African
Savannah,
well that's something.
It's a,
you know,
a few million years anyways,
but to me that's still icing on the
cake.
It's not deep enough.
This is way deeper now.
The metaphysics.
Okay,
well let's talk about the metaphysics.
Okay.
Who's idea of God?
Are you talking about?
It's like it's got an old man with a
beard and he lives in the sky.
Okay,
well let's take that argument apart a
little bit.
Okay.
First of all,
the ancient Jews,
they didn't like you to say the name of
God.
Why?
Because they didn't want you to confuse
the representation with the phenomena,
so whatever was real for them was
something beyond words.
Okay?
The same thing obtains with the Dow is
the same idea,
right?
Don't make a image because
you confuse the damn image with the
thing.
What's the thing?
It's that which is beyond the imaging
does that which beyond is beyond imaging
exist obviously.
What's its nature?
Well,
that's a different question.
Now in the Old Testament,
it's nature is arbitrary and it's like,
look,
the hell out.
You're going to get swatted down.
But if you look carefully at the
structure of the Old Testament and
northrop Frye did this,
fries argument was basically this,
well,
you've got the really old stories.
Forget about that.
History starts basically with Abraham
was the old testament about the
Israelites climb up to dominance.
They get corrupt,
they forget about the widows and the
children.
God,
a prophet comes up and says,
you better look out.
You're off the path.
They ignore him.
WHAP,
they're in chaos for a long time.
They get all humble and they build
themselves up again and when they get
power,
they get all corrupt and a prophet comes
along and says,
you better look out.
You're off the path.
You're not paying attention to the
widows and the children and all hell's
gonna break loose,
like bang down.
They go six times,
six times,
so you know,
is that arbitrary or is that actually
the right idea to derive from history?
It's like power corrupts,
so you make your kingdom,
you make your empire and it's serving
its proper purpose,
but you let it get corrupt.
Things are going to fall apart.
So I can give you an example of that.
It's like what caused the flooding in
New Orleans hurricane?
No,
no corruption.
If the dikes would've been built
properly,
as everyone knew,
they should have been built.
If all those millions of dollars had
gone into the pockets of corrupt
politicians,
there wouldn't have been any flood in
Holland.
They build the dikes for the worst storm
in 10,000
years in New Orleans.
They built them for the worst storm in
100 years.
Well,
everyone knew that was insufficient,
so why didn't they do something about
it?
Well,
if you get corrupt enough,
God will send a flood.
It's like it's an old story.
It's,
it's right.
It's right.
Now.
The question is,
who is God?
Where all I would say that the ancient
Israelites never made.
They never said who god was.
They just said,
look,
the hell out for him.
You deviate from the path,
man.
You're going to get flattened.
The people who wrote that book,
first of all,
like it was assembled loosely as a book,
right?
It's a bunch of books.
That's what Bible means.
It was edited and assembled across vast
stretches of time.
We have no idea what process led people
to assemble it that way,
except that they felt that that made
sense.
You know?
So they were guided by their intake,
internal intuition of meaning.
Weirdly enough,
it produced a document with a narrative.
Now the narrative is difficult in some
ways to discern,
given all the detail,
you know,
so I would say give our ancestors
a break for God's sake.
What do you want?
You want absolute perfect coherence when
they're trying to be so inclusive.
Like it's very hard to be coherent when
you're trying to be inclusive.
Those two things battle.
So you know,
have a little respect.
That's what,
that's how it looks to me.
Those people weren't stupid.
They were seriously not stupid and what
they thought was not stupid.
Now we can.
We can look at it another ways.
Why is God in the sky?
Well,
I know you can't see it in the city.
What's the fastest way to see infinity?
I'll look up at the night sky.
It's like,
why is God up there?
Because when you look at the night sky,
that's how you feel.
So is that wrong?
Well,
it's not bad,
you know,
it's like,
well where's the infinite?
Because that's really the question.
Well it seems to be up there.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
Okay.
So you make your sacrifices.
It's like,
why do people do that?
God,
that's primitive.
It's like,
no,
the invention of the sacrifice was
probably the single greatest stroke of
genius that mankind ever
was.
Was,
was given or produced.
What is the sacrifice?
You give up something of value now so
that things might be better in the
future.
It's like that's the human discovery.
That's the human discovery of time.
Everybody makes sacrifices.
It's like,
I'm going to go to university instead of
partying and snorting cocaine.
It's like,
because that's fun.
Why?
Well,
because if I organize my behavior
properly and I make the right
sacrifices,
God will smile on me in the future.
Or at least the probability seems
enhanced.
It's like,
okay,
well we don't use the same terminology.
What we use the same terminology.
We don't burn rabbits,
you know,
but then again,
we're not agriculturalists.
So the people who are playing with the
idea of sacrifice,
like they were acting out the discovery
of time,
you can give up something now try to get
a bone from a dog and tell them you're
going to give him two boats.
So like he doesn't give a damn about
that bone.
Now you know,
and we regard the civilized person as
the person who's capable of deferring
gratification.
Deferring gratification is a sacrifice.
Does it please God?
Well,
everyone thinks so or they wouldn't do
it.
So the burden,
the sacrifice,
why?
Well,
God's in heaven,
how else is it going to figure out the
quality of your sacrifice?
Well,
you might say,
well,
that's primitive.
It's like,
don't be so sure.
It's like they got to sacrifice idea,
right?
They go out to all part,
Like they're acting it out.
It's concretized.
It's like a drama.
Does that make it primitive?
Well,
no,
it's not primitive.
It's unbelievably sophisticated.
It's ridiculously sophisticated because
the mode in the old testament is you
make the right sacrifices and you will
thrive.
Just like,
do we believe that it's the basis of
civilized behavior.
You've don't get a complex civilization
without presupposition.
I think we've actually done quite well.
Good,
good.
It's hard to keep to a linear track.
Another problem with this kind of
material,
it's like you can call that the process
of coming to terms with this material,
a circumambulation,
a continual wandering around,
a center know,
and you sort of specify the center by
almost by inference,
so it's,
it's,
it's one of the things that make us very
difficult to read because everything
that he says is dependent on all the
other things he said.
That's one of the problems I ran into
when I was reading maps of meaning to.
It's like there's a presupposition at
the bottom that you have to accept in
order to follow the logic and the
presupposition is there are alternative
ways of laying out your initial
presuppositions about the nature of
reality.
It's like,
well,
why should I accept that while I can't
show you why until you accept it,
because I can't walk you through the
argument.
It's a paradigm problem.
Fundamentally.
So.
So the way I did that in maps of meaning
was that it was kind of like a small
circle to begin with and then a bigger
circle and then a bigger circle and you
know,
so I could get all the elements
described in a simple way and then make
it a little more complex than a little
more complex.
And that seemed to work to some degree
anyways.
There's something,
I mean not the music of panic,
but there's something so compelling
about it I think largely in part because
that basic precept position is not
articulated well or even accepted in the
sorts of science or social science that
we learned in university.
Well that's partly why it's so shallow.
The social science in particular,
it's like,
man,
it's unbelievable.
This like I should be careful about
that.
I learned a lot from animal
experimentalists a lot and from
neuroscientists,
but mostly the ones working on animals.
They learn things.
And part of that was a consequence of
behaviorism,
which was,
you know,
a very reductionistic method.
Useful,
you know.
So it's like,
it's not like I dismissed the capacity
of science to produce useful
information.
It's like,
but I'm also terrified of it,
you know,
it's like there's no reason to be so
optimistic about scientific truth.
You know?
The other thing that,
that I've noticed about the rash and
lists the empiricists,
you know,
they're sort of often the same corner,
is that they always make the assumption
that if we transcend our historical
religions will no longer be religious
and what we will be as rational.
It's like,
I think,
no,
you're,
you're completely out of your cotton
picking mind.
If you think that.
It's like,
well,
how do you account for the emergence of
new age philosophy?
It's like if you want incoherent,
just take a wander through that desert.
It's like you blow out these
historically this,
these carefully constructed historical
frameworks.
What you get is like rampant and insane
protestantism.
The idea that people will magically
become like Newton because we blown out
the substructure road morality like
that's so.
That's so absurd that that's the sort of
thought that I think is motivated.
It's like there's a reason to believe
that because who the hell would believe
that it's just you don't know anything
about people.
If you believe that people are,
it's hard to think scientifically.
It's really hard.
Here's a way of thinking too.
You can think,
you can reduce religion to,
to sort of Darwinian principles and sort
of destroy it that way,
you know,
or you can expand your notion of
Darwinism.
So that actually encompasses the genuine
phenomena of religion.
Man,
that is way more interesting,
but the problem is it's also the
problem.
The reason that people won't read young
first.
He's very difficult.
Second,
he is terrifying.
It's terrifying to reveal so well
because it means no one thinks like,
like he thought,
nobody thinks like that.
I mean he,
his grasp of the development of ideas
stretched over,
like I said,
10,000
years.
It,
it puts the enlightenment thinkers to
shame,
but,
but the,
if you start grappling seriously with
the idea that ideas have people instead
of people having ideas,
that forces you to reevaluate the entire
nature of your being.
Does.
The other thing he asked is which ideas
have you and where are they?
Where are,
where are they suggesting that you go
and like,
that's like the Greek God idea,
right?
We're play things of the gods like,
well,
don't darken already.
Darkens already knows about memes.
These are like metal memes and so let's
not be too in cautious about who's in
control here.
So it's like,
okay,
well you've developed a nihilistic
philosophy that's predicated on
rationalism.
Fine.
Why?
Who's behind that?
Precisely you.
It's like he had,
right?
No Way.
Thousand other people wouldn't think
exactly the same way if it was you,
you're just in its grip and what's it up
to the.
It's up for the betterment of humanity.
Sure.
Maybe,
but you know,
I wouldn't bet my life on it when you
wrote about Alchemy,
which his writings on alchemy are
incredibly opaque,
but I can give you a bit of an insight
into them.
You can understand young's readings on
copy.
If you start from the presupposition
that the matter that alchemists were
studying wasn't matter,
it was information.
Now you know the relationship between
matter and information is very complex
and some people think the substrate of
things is information and matt matter is
sort of an emergent property,
whatever.
It's complicated.
Now,
if you're studying information,
you can't study it objectively precisely
because as you study the information,
you get informed that changes you.
And so the problem with studying this
sort of thing is that you can't study it
without being changed because if you're
not changed by studying it,
you're not studying it.
It's not your no anthropologist who's
outside of this.
You can't be because if you're outside
of it,
you don't understand it because if you
understand it,
then you're not the same person anymore.
So you can't keep it at bay.
And so that's also partly why humans is
terrifying.
You know,
there's this I read and I don't remember
where,
you know,
there's a crucifix,
has Latin letters on the top of it and
it's Inri.
It means it's,
it's the representation of Jesus Christ,
King of the Jews,
hypothetically that was put on his
cross.
Um,
there's an occult interpretation of
that,
which is also Latin,
which I can't remember,
but it means all nature is renewed by
fire.
And so the,
the crucifixion then is assimilated to
the idea of a forest fire.
Everything burns down before there's new
growth.
If you study religion properly,
it will demolish your personality,
your personality,
the personality that's you is like the
dead branches on a,
on a pine tree.
So like you might be clinging to them
because you think,
well,
I'm all these dead branches.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
but first of all,
you should let go of the and second you
should let them burn off and then you
might think,
well,
I don't want them to burn off because
that's me.
It's like,
yeah,
that's true,
but it's,
it's the false you that you're clinging
to.
Well that doesn't mean you want to be
burned up in the flames.
So to study this material properly is to
be burned up in the flames and there's
no escaping that.
You're just not in it.
If you're.
If that doesn't happen,
you don't get it.
Like one of the things I realized when I
started studying this was that virtually
everything I said was a lie.
I would say 99 percent.
And by lie I mean it was manipulative.
It was unclear,
it was vague and that was all often
motivated or it was a false attempt to
gain dominance status,
which is typical of someone who's
intellectuals like,
well,
I've got these ideas,
I've taken them from places and now I
can use them as say,
status,
weapon,
something like that,
which is what people do when they're
trying to win an argument.
Say it's like that's all lies.
It's like,
well,
that's rough when it's 99 percent of
what you say,
first of all,
the first thing you realize is how much
you aren't.
You're not neat.
You know,
you're,
you have your experience as your claim
to reality and it's often pretty thin.
But,
but the development of authentic speech
is worth the price that you have to pay
for it.
So,
but you just can't stay detached from
this.
This isn't the phenomenon to study.
It's like the basis of.
It's the basis of being so,
so on that note,
because that's,
that's,
uh,
an expression of your experience really
delving in depth into the material.
Whereas there are other researchers
looking at this from a,
from a different angle.
I'm not saying it's more or less valid,
it's just different.
Right,
and they're looking at this from a why
not necessarily why or how does religion
come about?
Where did these ideas come from and why
are they important so much as once
they're there,
why do they perpetuate?
Why are they successful?
Why do religions exists when they seem,
when there's seems to be so much that or
rationalist would find objectionable or
just.
Sure.
So then that begs the question,
whose silly?
The rationalist assumes that it's not
him.
It's like,
okay,
let's have some evidence while we can
fly to the moon.
Fair enough.
That's one form of evidence.
How long has this been working?
Two hundred years.
Okay.
Let's say rate rated for a million years
and see what happens right now.
You know when you can object to that
because you can say,
well,
who knows where the future will lead and
so on,
but my point is is that,
well,
it's again,
it's what you assume to be true
structures your argument and you have to
assume something to be true because you
don't have infinite knowledge.
So you make that initial choice.
Why?
While it might be because you're a true
truth seeker.
Well,
I would be careful about making that
claim.
Right?
Because you're probably not.
So then who are you
innovated by something that we're not
aware of that
is that there's no probably about that.
Yeah.
Not only that,
you might be motivated by terrible
things that you're not aware of,
like truly terrible things.
You know,
one of the things he said about the
shadow which was for him that was sort
of all those parts of you that weren't
very developed and are mad about it
because you're like,
you know,
trying to kill them and all those sort
of storehouse of lies and deception that
you've managed and all the things you've
left on done and the motivations for
doing all that.
It's like that's the shadow said,
well the shadow is rooted in hell and,
and you know,
you think,
well that's a nice metaphor.
It's like,
don't be so sure it's a metaphor.
It's not exactly a metaphor.
I mean,
I can,
I can elaborate on that a little bit.
If you walk down bloor street and you
watch,
you can see people in hell with no
problem.
I think they're not only the people who
are completely lost the homeless,
but the homeless that you cannot look at
and the reason you can't look at them is
because they find your act of mirroring
their state of existence intolerable.
It will instantly enrage them and that's
because they're in chaos there in the
underworld,
but they're in a particular suburb of
the underworld and that little suburb
that's hell.
And you think,
well,
is it a more,
is it eternal?
Depends what you mean.
It's been around a long time.
It's been around a long time and it's
really deep.
And there's another weird thing about
hell,
which is if you're in it,
no matter how bad it is,
there's some stupid thing you can do to
make it worse.
And that's why it's bottomless.
It's not obvious.
What's a metaphor?
You know?
Does Heaven Exist?
Depends on what you mean.
I think people get glimpses of it all
the time.
Those are,
those are the times in your life when
the meaning shines through,
it's like that's a place when the
meaning shines through.
That's a place like if you conceptualize
things as four dimensional,
this place shifts with time.
So we're actually sitting in a multitude
of places here now and then that place
configures itself so that it's as
perfect as it can be.
You get a glimpse and then you think,
well,
what?
What if it could always be like that.
It's like,
well,
what if it could be always like that?
And also you might say,
for example,
what would happen if everybody told the
truth?
We know what happens when people don't.
You get the Gulag archipelago.
What's the opposite of that?
Well,
we don't know.
We do know that there's an opposite
though,
so people are in cautious about their
discussions of what constitutes real.
They don't even notice their own
experience.
You've never been to the underworld,
so like you've been there every time
things have fallen apart in your life.
I tell people that all the time in my
lectures.
Here's what the underworld meets.
You've been married for 10 years,
you're happily married,
you come home,
your wife's go on.
There's a note that says I'm leaving
with my lover of the last 10 years.
It's like,
well,
you were somewhere before you walked
into the house and now you're somewhere
different.
Where are you now?
What year where you go when the bottom
drops out,
where's that?
Well,
it's in the underworld like here in the
underworld.
You're in that chaotic state that exists
before order is constructed.
You go there all the time
and the reason people can't,
can't see the connection between their
experience and these earlier,
um,
mythological representations is because
people are being adequate mystic and
reinterpreting the mythological
representations as if their scientific
theories as if these people were naive
scientists,
really what they were doing is coming up
with images to explain things that they
otherwise represent.
But we're real in terms of their lived
experience.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Why?
Why would we think they were naive
scientist?
What?
What is a chimp a naive scientist like?
It's just silly.
It's it.
They weren't live scientists,
whatever they were doing.
Well,
I think they were naive
phenomenologists,
but they weren't very naive.
They weren't concerned with material
reality.
They were concerned with the nature of
being.
It's not.
I mean that's heidegger's claim,
right?
He believed that.
And I again,
I didn't know this until much later.
Heidegger believe that philosophy
actually lost its way with the Greeks,
with Plato for example,
when things became rationalized,
Nicha thought the same thing in many
ways because he was very interested in
the Dionysian right.
Which is more like,
well that's more like lived experience,
the Dionysian,
you know,
that's the chemist who goes out and you
know,
maybe he's a punk rocker in his spare
time and he goes out in the evening and
listens to a,
you know,
a thrash metal band in bounds himself
against other people.
It's like,
it doesn't see any contradiction there.
well,
one's rational and now there isn't.
That's a contradiction,
you know?
And while you find the irrational
activity enjoyable,
well how do you account for that?
You don't just keep the world separate.
It's like,
so these are ancestors were
phenomenologists and they were
accounting for the,
their,
their landscapes.
There,
the geography of being straight.
Well there's an underworld.
Well,
when do you go there?
when,
when things fall apart,
it's like,
that's where you end up.
Like everyone gets that,
you know,
I tell these stories to retirees and all
sorts of people say,
well look,
you know,
there's a place that you go.
When everything falls apart,
it's like,
oh,
I've been there.
Then the question is,
well,
what do you do when you get there?
Because everybody needs to know that
that's another thing that religious
stories or trying to tell you when
things fall apart,
what do you do?
Well,
we don't think of when things fall apart
as a place,
but that's our problem.
It's a place.
I mean people live in del you'd have to
do is go look on the street.
So like,
oh look,
that person's in the underworld.
It's like adding that person's inhale
and you can tell,
but you won't look.
Hey.
You know,
what usually happens in a circumstance
like that is there is so much inhale
that you'll just walk around them and
you will look at them.
Why not?
You don't want to go there.
Yeah,
that's right.
That expression in English.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
So there,
there is encoded in the way we think
there is this inherent locality or
geographies.
Yeah.
Well,
and it is a geography,
like it's,
it's a,
it's a slice of space time,
you know,
so you know,
it's also the street,
but it's not just the street,
it's,
it's the being of the street,
it's everything that's,
that's afforded by the representation of
street.
Nevermind,
it has,
it has other meanings beyond what we do,
which is something that we didn't touch
on at all actually,
which we had,
which is as the complexity management
theory angle in the sense that how we
compartmentalize reality is not at all a
given,
right?
I mean,
no,
you do it on the fly,
right?
And you do it for pragmatic reasons,
you know,
and so in some sense what you do is you
look for the simplest possible and least
energetic way of conceptualizing the
current situation so that the next thing
you want to do happens.
It's something like that.
And I like to think about it in terms of
resolution,
you know,
because I think resolutions are really
useful idea.
Most of our representations of reality
are extremely low resolution,
like will rely on a thumbnail,
well why not?
What's good enough?
Right?
It's pragmatic,
it's good enough,
you know,
don't make it any more complex than it
has to be.
And what you are managing always is
complexity because the thing that
you're,
the representation you use,
which is an image,
let's say,
is a low resolution representation of
the reality behind the image.
So for example,
you're sitting there,
okay,
well I can't see your back so I can't
see your family.
I can't see your culture.
I can't see your education.
I can't see the biosphere that you're an
embedded part of.
I can't see any of your substructures.
It's like they're all there.
They're just as real as the thing that I
see.
They're causally implicated in
everything that you do.
It's like that's complexity.
So you know,
maybe you know,
I'm assuming that you're,
you're,
I'm assuming that you're what we both
decided to allow to be possible here,
right?
Because we're both polite.
We're doing this little act that,
you know,
we both agree on,
we've never met,
but we were going to run this routine.
We're going to play by the rules.
But you know,
like for all I know you could just turn
left right now.
You know,
and then all of a sudden all that
complexity is like,
it's there.
That's chaos.
It's like that's a potential too because
maybe I think,
well,
what we're doing is too mundane,
boring,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm caught in it.
It's like I hope you turned left a
little bit because then that's the water
of life to that,
you know,
that refreshing complexity comes back.
But hopefully not too much of it.
Right?
I don't want too much of it.
I want a little bite size piece of it
that will make me interested in not
terrified.
So that's complexity and that's,
that's a better way of conceptualizing
what the terror management guys are
after with regards to the fear of death,
you know?
So partly I don't think they're very
imaginative.
There's much many worse things than
death to be terrified of.
Like insanity is probably one,
you know,
pain that's a bad one.
Longterm pain,
that's a bad one.
Well then there's longterm pointless
pain,
you know,
then there's your longterm pointless
pain and that of your family.
Like there's,
there's horrors that exceed death by
orders of.
So to make that,
the fundamental fear I think is.
I think that's an error.
You know,
it's like,
what are people more afraid of dying or
having their children die?
You know,
that's,
that's a perfectly reasonable question.
So I read Becker,
really read it.
Like I liked Becker's book.
It's brilliant,
but he makes a bunch of mistakes for one
of the things he does,
for example,
is right in the intro,
he says it's a book that's trying to
bring about the psychoanalytic closure
of the study of religion.
So it's Neil Freud in smartly,
neil frightened and he wants to explain
religion pretty much completely within
the psychoanalytic framework,
does a great job,
but in the intro he says,
well,
you might wonder why in a book that's
devoted to the last word in
psychoanalytic thinking about religion,
I never mentioned you.
So then he says a bunch of things about
young.
One of them is I could never understand
a single thing he was talking about when
he wrote all his works on alchemy.
It's like,
oh,
well that's a problem because that's
where all the information that your book
lacks is all of it.
You missed it.
It's like,
yeah,
you're thinking about the hero myth,
for example,
as a delusion and you know,
as a hero project and has something
that's only there to stave off the fear
of death.
It's like,
well you got a good way into the depths
but,
and way farther than most people get,
but you missed the next 300 stories.
So.
And that's too bad.
So you know,
and it's funny because I've also read
the social psychology,
a fair bit of it that is associated with
Tara management and most of the problem
with it is it hasn't moved becker one
inch.
It's like,
yeah,
that's what Becker said.
So we're proving it.
Well no,
not really because the demonstrations
are amenable to multiple
interpretations,
but Becker he covered it.
I mean it's a brilliant book,
but it's wrong.
So,
so on that note is this argument is
wrong for people that may not have read
it back or they're not fully aware of
the terror management theory.
Well,
because he thinks he thinks of
everything that we do to contend with
mortality as Ann Rousse,
you know,
and I don't think that's right because I
don't think that it's necessary to be
terrified of death now.
It's not easy not to be,
but you know,
it's fate that as far as Becker's
concerned is that that's what you're
going to be terrified.
It's like,
well,
I don't think that that's right.
I think that people don't have to be
terrified of death.
It's not an easy state to achieve.
It's not like I want to die.
Although I can certainly imagine things
that are worse than that,
like no problem.
So I think,
and this is something sold units and
laid out in the Gulag archipelago too,
I think there are ways of living that
are worse than death.
That's why people commit suicide.
That's their decision.
So obviously hell is worse than death,
you know,
given how I described it earlier.
So it isn't death.
That's the problem.
It's complexity.
That's the problem is that things are
beyond us.
Because of that,
they always exceed what our models tell
us they're going to do,
or they always transformed themselves in
some ungainly ways so that we don't get
what we want.
So then the question is,
well,
how do you best deal with complexity?
And the reason I think truth is so
useful is because generally it reduces
complexity,
right?
I mean,
one of the things that's really useful
about trying to say things that you
believe to be true is you don't have to
remember what you said.
It's like,
well,
what did I say?
Well,
I don't know,
but I was trying to explain things
properly.
Then you don't have to tear through all
your rationalizations and think about
what you have to keep track of like
deceptions.
They grow,
you know,
they're like hydrus so well,
don't do that.
Okay,
truth simpler.
That's one big advantage.
You know,
and people can say,
well,
truth isn't always the answer.
Well,
there are some times you get into a
situation that's so awful.
You've made so many mistakes that not
only would it be very difficult for
truth to rescue you,
you've already worked your character to
such a degree that you couldn't even use
it.
Well,
you've had it,
you know,
you're,
you're off the radar at that point,
and nothing short of a miracle would
save you.
To what degree do you think that one of
the lessons that you've extrapolated and
you put it in,
you put it into words,
are,
are easily applied across various
cultures that you may not have
necessarily addressed in your
examination of mythology.
And I'm challenging you a little bit
here just because it's an interesting
topic.
For instance,
Islam just doesn't feature at all in the
work that you've written as I've as I've
read,
but it's,
it's a,
it's a hugely important religion on a
global scale.
And even in countries like Canada.
Um,
and then there's also the question of
with so many people coming with
different specific mythologies or
embodiments of the universe mythology
that we're discussing,
what are the,
I mean this is sort of a unique episode
in human history in the sense of just
the scale and the rapidity with which
people are coming into contact with each
other from very different backgrounds.
So what do you see as the implications
of that for good or for bad in a,
in a country like
Canada,
the fact that people are coming
together,
but from those very different cultural
places in which maybe there's a
universal mythology that,
that envelops all of them.
But the values and the particular
embodiments of mythology that people
have grown up with are often very
different than they and these and these
come,
these can clash.
I mean I'm not a,
not a tribal,
tribal,
tribal and I don't mean in a,
in a,
in the clash of civilizations sort of
overblown away.
But I'm just saying on a,
on a pragmatic level,
people are often operating in different
psychological space.
Well,
to some degree that the issue there is
whether or not you can negotiate,
right society,
a multicultural society in many ways is
dependent on negotiation.
And you know,
here's another sort of axiom.
It's tyranny,
slavery in negotiation.
Those are your options.
You want to be a tyrant?
Fine,
you're going to be a slave,
that's an option,
but if you don't want to be either of
those,
you'd negotiate,
okay?
So how do you negotiate or partly you
pay attention so you listen.
And so now here's another way to think
about it.
Just like the totality,
your tarion assumes that what he knows
will redeem him to sort of the basis of
terror management theory in some sense,
right?
So what you know protects you and keeps
you safe,
okay?
And so you want to tighten that up and
you want to make it rigorous and you
don't want anything to exist outside of
it.
Okay?
Now they're so,
so in some ways you worship the great
father.
That's a way of thinking about it.
Here's another way of thinking about it.
What you don't know will redeem you.
Well,
why?
because you already know what you know
and now then you can ask yourself,
well,
is that enough?
And then that the answer to that is,
well,
what's the quality of your life if the
quality of your life is what you want it
to be,
really then what you know is enough,
but the probability that your quality of
life is what you want it to be is very
low because you're still prone to all
sorts of suffering and all sorts of
ignorance and and you know you can face
that forthrightly.
It's one of the things that didn't
happen in the Soviet Union because
everybody said,
my quality of life is great.
We know everything we need to know when
in reality it was like abysmal,
murderous,
treacherous,
deceitful.
It was horrible,
but you know,
so what that meant,
it was at that in the Soviet Union.
If you admitted to ward,
if you admitted to your own suffering,
you were a trader.
Well,
that's the.
That's hell.
So you can't even let your suffering be
true,
right?
Not only do you have to suffer,
but you can't even admit it.
Okay?
So back to listening,
it's like,
well,
if you assume that what you don't know
his redemptive,
then you can listen,
you can listen because he never know.
That person might know something that
you don't know and maybe that would be a
useful something you know and maybe you
have something to say that they don't
know that would be useful.
You know,
now there's some presuppositions that go
along with that.
It's like you have to be willing to meet
the other person in the space between
cultures and you have to know how to
operate in this space between cultures.
And that's part of the hero myth.
By the way,
if you're a hero of the right form,
you knew how to operate in this space
between cultures.
Well then how do you operate there?
Well,
I think we know what makes cultures
rich.
Trust what makes trust possible.
Honesty,
you know you want natural resources.
There's nothing more valuable than trust
and honesty.
Why is the world poor?
Corruption?
That's why all the poor countries,
almost all the poor countries are
corrupt.
Part of the reason they're poor is
because they're corrupt.
Now,
you know,
you might say,
well,
are the western countries so uncorrupt?
It's like,
well they've got their problems,
but generally the answer is they're not
corrupt.
So [inaudible] bay is a good example of
that,
you know,
because when Ebay first emerged,
people thought,
you send me John,
could I send you a check that bounces?
So that's the end of Ebay,
right?
So these third party,
I can't remember what they're called,
agents set themselves up so that you
could pay them a fraction of the price
and they would get the check and the
product validate them and ship them off
and you know,
they'd take 10 percent or whatever.
There's a particular name for people who
do that,
like it's a profession.
Anyways,
what happened was the average rate of
honesty on Ebay was so high that that
was useless.
It's like the default was I won't screw
you.
And that was between strangers who had
never met an even more weirdly.
We're never going to engage in another
transaction.
So what that meant was that Ebay all of
a sudden became insanely valuable
because people would trade property now,
re reputation markers soon evolved,
but the d,
and I do believe that in the west the
default is you won't screw me now if
that means that I can trust your
persona.
If the default is you will screw me,
then I'm a barrel of snakes and you're a
barrel of snakes and we will never get
anywhere
exactly.
But this is,
I mean,
if we talked about the state of the
world,
most of humanity does not live in the
west where the default assumption is I
can probably trust this person.
What are the lessons to learn from what?
From what you're arguing and from and
from where you've extrapolated from your
experience or these contexts.
Okay.
I mean,
I can only speak about that at the most
general level because what to do in any
particular circumstance.
That's the sort of problem I deal with
in my clinical practice all the time.
It's like,
here's this insanely complicated
circumstance.
It's usually has nothing to do with
mental illness is just the per person is
caught in something ridiculously
complex.
Like you know,
their aunt is sick at home,
their husband just lost his job and they
have an illness.
It's like,
oh my God,
it's horrible.
You know,
is it,
are they mentally ill?
It's no,
it's just awful.
So how do you weave your way through an
awful situation while the particulars
matter a lot.
And so you have to do strategic
analysis,
paying attention to the details,
but okay,
so that's the particular.
So what's the general case?
While the general case is
maybe
don't falsify your relationship with
being to the degree that you can manage
that.
Now one of the things that I tell my
students is
try solving a problem,
fixing it,
not trying to solve a problem,
but you know,
if you're gonna fix it and you can fix
it and it's a problem and you know,
it's a problem.
Okay.
So there's like a preconditioning.
So let's say there's a bunch of things
around you that bug you and you think,
hmm,
those things bug me.
Why?
But you don't know.
But they bug you and you might think,
well,
is one of those things that bugged me,
something I could fix,
you might think well On.
And there's another part which is
normally,
could I fix it?
I would fix it because you can think,
well I could fix that,
but I won't know if you're being honest.
You know,
he just won't do it.
But there's often something that you
would fix.
Start there,
fix it,
and then try again.
Try to see if there's something else you
could fix.
Like.
So if you're going to beat the lie,
you know you have to start with what you
can do and you start locally like right,
right.
Locally.
And you can tell it's the right amount
of local because it bugs you.
You could fix it and you will fix it.
So perfect.
That's your problem.
That's exactly your problem right there.
Fix it.
Well then everything shifts a little
bit.
Everything around you is just.
The balance between chaos and order is a
little better.
Right?
Well the same thing applies to your
speech.
It's like,
okay,
I have to lie here because otherwise I'm
going to get killed.
It's like,
okay,
well maybe that's not the place to
start.
You know the baby that's just foolhardy.
Okay.
What I say that you should lie in that
situation,
I would say I can't tell because I'm not
in the situation and the particular
matter,
so I don't know what to say.
That situation might be so awful that
there's nothing you can do that isn't
awful.
How about in your own home?
How but in relationship to yourself,
it's like,
how about you start fixing up the little
micro lies that you leave lying around
everywhere.
Then it's gonna make you tougher and
more formidable.
You keep practicing that for like 15
years,
you know,
and then maybe you'll be able to start
to address some of the larger problems.
Maybe you'll even start to understand
what the larger problems are because
that's a problem with prematurely trying
to do too much.
Right?
It's like,
oh,
is that really the problem?
And what makes you think you'll make it
better rather than worse?
It's got to pick the right size problem.
So I would say,
you know,
let's start with little weights and work
yourself up and that's how you develop
competence anyways,
right?
Like if you're going to figure out how
to set things straight,
you might as well start where you can
set them straight and you might think,
well that's trivial.
It's not trivial.
You might think it's trivial.
You have no idea how important it might
be that you straighten up your,
your relationship with your,
your wife or your son.
You may have no idea what that might
lead to.
I mean,
just think of what Stella and his
relationship with his father led to.
It was awful.
You know,
their salad,
he killed like $60 million people.
His father was a brute,
so that seemed reasonably important.
Maybe he shouldn't have been a brute.
So.
So you know how horrible things can be
if you do things wrong.
It's like,
well,
how good can they be if you do things
right?
You don't know.
Try starting.
It's like see what happens.
My experience has been like I'm.
My experience has been that to the
degree that I'm able to speak carefully
and I do speak carefully and I don't
really care about the consequences.
It isn't that it isn't,
that they don't matter.
It's that I'm not speaking to produce a
consequence.
I'm just trying to say what seems to me
to be the case and that for me that's
been incredibly ridiculously.
I'm practically useful,
insanely useful.
Like it's opened doors that I would've
never dreamed of opening.
So,
and you know,
in my professional life it's produced
all sorts of opportunities and it's been
a real aid in my private life to it in
my professional life.
It's not like I don't make mistakes like
I,
I don't think that I am.
I would never think of myself as
fundamentally a good person.
I think maybe I'm fundamentally a bad
person,
but because our,
you know,
I have dark thoughts and,
and I,
I'm quite temperamental.
And so like
anyways,
you know,
I do what I can to deal with all that
and I don't do it perfectly.
And I slide backwards mostly by
avoidance,
you know,
I don't always stay on top of the things
I should stay on top of,
but
to the degree that I've been able to
adhere to this mode of being,
I can't think of a single thing that's
happened that hasn't been
like in some ways beyond my
expectations.
So.
And it's really fun talking to this
students,
you know,
because it's fun with the lectures
because when I'm talking about the
mythological material and I can sort of
sort out the stories,
I can just see lights going on
everywhere.
It's like click,
you know,
you can see,
it's like you can tell when someone has
an insight,
I think they opened their eyes a bit
more detail.
Maybe that's it because it's a bit of a
surprise so you can detect it and it is
like light going on.
And so,
you know,
I'll walk someone suit three,
say through this Egyptian story and
audience and they just go pick to click,
click,
click.
It's fun,
it's really fun.
So,
and you know,
people seem to respond to it positively,
which I've always been completely
surprised about,
you know,
I can't,
that I've been able to lecture about the
things that I lecture about without,
you know,
running mightily afoul of something,
because my classes are quite different
than the standard psychology class or
the standard university class.
They're very different and.
But that,
but I don't know so far it seems to be
working.
So which is a surprise to me.
So.
So that's what I would say to people is
like select the domain in which you can
act straightened it up first and that'll
transform things a bit.
Like,
it'll,
you put your house in order,
then you can start to put your town in
order or maybe your street or maybe your
neighbor.
God only knows,
you know,
start where you can start.
And you might think,
well that's what's that.
Well,
it's nothing you can wave a placard in
the street about,
which is a good thing that's like
praying in public,
you know,
this is more like praying in private fix
up what you can fix up and see what
happens.
And I don't think that there's anything
that's more powerful than that.